welcome everybody to rochford district
council's remote council meeting of the
15th of december 2020
and a particular warm welcome to anybody
watching
this fire our live live screen
stream i shall take item one on the
agenda apologies for absence i've
received apologies from councillor
burton
are there any others
no thank you members item
two on the agenda minutes of the meeting
held on the 20th of october
2020. you've all received copies
members are you happy for me to sign in
due course the minutes of the meeting
held on the 20th of october
i would assume agreement unless you
unless anyone clicks on the raise
hand icon
there are no raise hand icon and that's
been approved thank you members i shall
sign them
as a say in due course agenda item three
declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest members
so we've got council williams council
williams
thank you chairman um item 12
um non-binary interest being vice chair
of investment board
thank you
anybody else no
thank you very much
so but i did have my head raised yeah
i can't hear
council arena shaw uh thank you chairman
i'm
also a member of the investment world
sites for item
12 if needed to be noted thank you
anybody else if i may
of the investment board bar the chairman
and the vice chairman
thank you okay
no other interests to be noted members
i shall go back to item four
announcements from the chairman leader
or head of paid service
members i would like to take this
opportunity to congratulate
councillor tony carter who was
shortlisted
for the lgiu local government
information unit 2020
council rewards and was highly commended
under the cataract category of
covet 19 euro councillor tony carter was
nominated by councillor christine mason
after volunteering to retrain his
nursing assistants in order to help
during the pandemic
my congratulations councillor and thank
you for all you've done
i would also like to take this
opportunity to thank all those
councillors who have helped and
continues to help
those in our community in most need
during these
unprecedented times you are all
unsung heroes the leader of the council
would also like to make an announcement
councillor woodson
thank you chairman and good evening to
everyone um tomorrow or possibly later
tonight
the new portfolio holder strap chart
will be uh
circulated but i thought it would be
helpful just to
go through the key headlines for members
this evening
i am delighted to welcome council
councillor danielle
belton who joins the executive team with
responsibility for the newly named
portfolio
commercial business local economy and
leisure which replaces the old
enterprise portfolio
leisure switches to this portfolio given
the significant
financial support provided to fusion it
is important particularly over the next
couple of years
that there is close focus on their
performance as a business
finance is renamed financial services
continues under councillor simon smith
but responsibilities
remain unchanged planning
is renamed strategic planning under
councillor ian ward
as the name implies emphasis will be on
the strategic
infrastructure aspects of development
highways
transport and regeneration as well as
the creation
of the new local plan environment
is renamed environment and place under
council arthur williams
and it now includes the impacts of
climate change
and air quality in the district meetings
to do with the river crouch
and coastal matters will now fall within
this portfolio
whilst community remains an unchanged
name under councillor mike webb
increased opportunities will be explored
towards community engagement
especially with younger people
councillor danielle
fd will head up the newly named i.t
tourism housing and parking portfolio
for the time being of the continuity the
implemented
implementation of actions from the
carpark working group
will be seen through by councillor hefty
housing and homelessness will also be
managed
under his portfolio in addition to the
standard strategic responsibilities as
leader
i will be overseeing the asset
development program until completion
i will also be reviewing how residents
and businesses
engage to ensure that the customer
experience with the council
continues to be positive as well as
supporting me and all my responsibility
responsibilities as deputy leader
council councillor
cheryl rose responsibilities will
include emphasis
upon council communications including
social media
transformation and the connect program
as i said earlier a new portfolio
organization chart will be circulating
to members tomorrow
thank you chairman thank you council
woodson members i'd like to take
item 5 on the agenda public
questions and member questions on notice
we have two member questions on notice
from council newport to the portfolio
holder for planning council award
council newport could you please read
out your first
question
can you just bear with me chairman
because i don't actually have
access to my email just bear with me
sorry
okay can you hear me i can and we can
yes okay
um council award via you chairman if i
may
as of the 30th of november 2020
how many planning enforcement cases were
outstanding
and my second question as i'm counseling
yeah i'll come to your second question
second
uh and respond to your first question
council ward uh
thank you very much for your question
council newport
um through you chairman i would just
like to ask
council newport if he would kindly
define um the meaning of outstanding for
me because
it uh i i need that clarified what does
he mean by
outstanding please well they're cases
that haven't been closed
by the enforcement officers
okay so you they haven't been okay thank
you very much for that council newport
that haven't been closed
okay uh we have at this moment 286
being investigated at this moment in
time
okay thank you thank you council newport
you do have the opportunity for a
supplementary question
do you have such a question no thank you
chairman
okay can you then please read out your
second question for council ward
as of the 30th of november 2020 how many
full-time planning officers
were directly employed by the council
and not on sick leave parental leave
or on holiday and for clarification that
um you can include part-time staff that
make up the equivalent of full-time
paying officers if you need to
council award council wall can you
respond to that please
yeah thank you very much chairman um i
shall
just give you the full quote on this one
council newport
the council at this moment employs 12
full-time planning officers of these
currently
and i'll give it 0.4 full-time stock
which is two days
is on maternity leave and will be
returning on the 23rd
of february 2021 there
is one full-time planning enforcement
officer
and there's a way to conceive of that
post so realistically we've got 12
full-time uh staff including planning
manager
four team leaders four senior planners
and three planners thank you
thank you council ward um casual newport
again you've got the opportunity of a
supplementary question do you have such
a question
um no that's fine thank you chairman
thank you
thank you members that concludes item
five
i shall now take item six of the agenda
business from last
from the last meeting members does
anyone have any questions relating to
the business from the council meeting
held on the 20th of october
2020 could you please indicate by
raising your blue hand icon
no such indication members
i shall then take item seven to note the
minutes
of the executive and committee meeting
meetings
held between the periods 7th of october
2020 to the 30th of november
2020 are these noted members
i will assume agreement unless you click
on your raised
hand icon
no such indication
no such indication members that's noted
thank you agenda item
eight to consider in reports from the
executive and committees to council
item eight one report of the review
committee 2020 stroke
21 mid-year treasury management review
council sparing vice chairman of the
review committee will introduce this
report
council sparing thank you chairman
this is a routine update of the
2020-2021
mid-year treasury management review
as usual it was very professionally
presented comprehensively so
by our 151 officer
going from memory chairman i don't think
there were any issues
raised from this report and in 1.3
of the executive report it is proposed
that the media
report be noted by a council
thank you council sparing members are
there any questions
on this item
i can see no indication of such uh
members
there is one recommendation at paragraph
1.3 of the report on page
8.1.1 that the contents of the treasury
management
mid-year report be noted and i will
assume
agreement unless anyone clicks on the
raise
hand icon
i can see no such indication members
that has been noted
item 82 this is a report of the review
committee
waste and recycling strategy and again
council sparing vice chairman of the
review committee will introduce this
item
council sparing thank you chairman um
this was a report to review committee on
the waste and recycling strategy
following a working party uh review
of the process and where we should go
from here it's probably one of the most
in-depth working parties that i've ever
been involved in
i think as you can see from the report
it covers just about
every aspect it gave members of the
review committee
an ideal opportunity to raise a number
of questions
which i believe were answered to members
satisfaction
as a result of of all this chairman uh
at the end of the executive on eight
page 8.2.2
there is a recommendation which i
propose
that the waste and recycling strategy
be adopted by council
members uh thank you council despairing
is there a is there a second though
chairman thank you
members um before we go to the vote can
you please
got cancer williams and your counselor
sorry council williams
sorry german i was just i put my hand up
to second the motion thank you
okay are there any other questions
counselor eves thank you um
it was just clarification please uh
we've got on
page 8.2.4 anticipate increasing demand
for service
um which is going to increase cost etc
we've always been
told when we've discussed
the income from the new house houses
built
that the council tax from that will be
cost neutral
and so can we have clarification that
the we are still looking at a cost
neutral
issue um with the waste collection
bearing in mind the increase in
properties that are going to become part
of our portfolio thank you
thank you council reeves um i shall ask
uh
mr marcus hotten assistant director
placed in the environment if he can
comment on that
i think i follow the thread of what
counts regions said so
forgive me if i if i answer this uh
in the wrong in the wrong sort of thing
um
the costs um to some degree are
we we'll follow obviously there is a
council tax contribution
um from each property but but at times
the
the cost of a contract doesn't
necessarily follow the
the sort of the number of houses
perfectly so that there are times there
are going to be costs that are stepped
um whether we like that or not so for
example you'll get to a certain capacity
in terms of um of vehicles and you will
need an additional vehicle additional
staff at that point
so the idea that it can naturally follow
uh a neat curve is probably not
completely true but certainly i mean
we would anticipate the um council tax
contributions go towards
uh running the refuse contract but but
it won't necessarily completely marry up
all the time
just due to that sort of stepping costs
so i hope that answers the question
thank you thank you mr holton
any other questions members
no one is indicating members therefore
before we go to the vote can you please
check your raised hand icon and
unmute your microphone and let me know
if you're not able to use the electronic
raised hand so everybody can use that
ray's hand
john mcpherson's got a handout
who is
mcpherson sorry
you're muted counselor macpherson
uh councilman cannot raise him okay then
so can you say cancer mcpherson is there
any but is there anyone else that's not
hurting you is that
is there anybody else who cannot raise
their race hand icon
okay members could you please raise your
raised hand icon
and unmute um if you would like
um a recorded vote to be taken
members there will be a recorded vote
i shall therefore undertake a recorded
vote and when i call your name please
indicate if you wish to vote for the
motion
against the motion or if you wish you
abstain from
voting
councillor mrs belton thank you
for the motion thank you council mrs
butcher thank you
for the motion thank you councillor
canel
for the motion thank you chair thank you
councillor mr carter
for a motion chairman thank you thank
you councillor mrs carter
oh thank you thank you myself councillor
dre
for the motion councillor fd
run a motion thank you chairman
councillor eves
four thank you chairman thank you
council gooding
for the motion thank you chair thank you
counselor hazelwood
poor thank you
councillor hawkway
not with us as yet cancer high four
thank you council hudson thank you
councillor ionu
for the motion chairman councillor lucas
gill
four chairman thank you councillor mrs
lumley
thank you councillor mrs mason
for the motion thank you councillor mrs
macpherson
for the motion chairman and apologies
for my technical difficulty
it's been resolved now thank you
councillor merrick
or councillor milne
all the motion chairman council newport
or councillor pavlin
for the motion thank you chairman
councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman four thank you
council mrs shaw
thank you chairman for councillor mr
shaw
or please chairman thank you councillor
smith
for council sparing
or council stanley
or thank you council steptoe
[Music]
council ward thank you
thank you council webb poor thank you
chairman
thank you councillor mrs weston chairman
thank you council wilkinson for chairman
thank you council williams thank you
chairman that's four
thank you council wilson for chairman
thank you councillor wooden
well thank you chairman
thank you members that item is
unanimously approved
thank you
members i shall now go on to item eight
three of the agenda
excuse me chairman it's vice chair can
we ask members to um put their hands
down there are two members with their
hands
unless they wanted to ask a question
thank you chairman we'll do this this
end thank you
council western um now go to item
83 report of the licensing and appeals
committee draft statement of licensing
policy council
gooding chairman of the licensing and
appeals committee will introduce this
report
councillor gooding thank you chairman
the statement of licensing policy is
reviewed every four years
the license and appeals committee met on
the first of july
to consider the statement of licensing
policy
only one amendment was made to the
policy
which was to remove the cumulative
impact policy
as there was no evidence to support it
instead rdc's statement of licensing
policy
now includes a paragraph which states
that where applications for new premises
licenses
or variations to premises license appear
likely to add to an existing impact
the applicants will need to demonstrate
why the operation
of these premises will not add to any
existing impact
the policy was then put out to full
consultation
from the 17th of august to the 6th of
november
2020 the licensing appeals committee
met again on the 17th of november 2020
only one response was received to the
consultation
relating to minor grammar
errors therefore the licensing and
appeals committee
recommends that the council approves the
updated policy
to commence from january 2021
i'd like to thank the officers and
members for their contribution to this
committee
and move the recommendation chairman
thank you councillor and mrs gooding
council cheryl rowe
thank you chairman i've second that
thank you councillor rowe members
are there any questions at all
no one's indicating members
there is one recommendation which has
been proposed
and seconded that the amended statement
of licensing policy
be approved but before we go to the vote
can you please raise
your hand icon and unmute your
microphone
should you wish a recorded vote to be
taken
okay
members there will be a recorded vote
um you know procedure um when i call
your name could you please let me know
if you're four against or wish to
abstain councillor mrs belton
four thank you thank you council mrs
butcher
the answer mrs butcher yes sorry i
couldn't unmute thank you chairman
four thank you councillor canel
for the mansion chair thank you sir
carter mr carter
all chairman please counselor mrs carter
oh thank you thank you myself
for the motion council fd on the motion
thank you chad
thank you councillor eves
councillor mrs gooding for the motion
thank you chairman
councillor hazelwood
oh counselor
still not with us councillor hoy
for thank you councillor hudson
or councillor ionu
i'll come back to you council lucas gill
poor german councillor mrs lumley
thank you councillor mrs mason
for the motion councillors mcpherson
four thank you chairman thank you
councilmerrick
paul thank you councilman
or mr chairman thank you council newport
or councillor mrs pavlin
oh thank you council mrs rowe
thank you chairman four thank you
council mrs shaw
thank you chairman for council mr shaw
for council smith
thank you council sparing or
council stanley
for thank you council steptoe
thank you council ward
chairman thank you council wilkinson
for chairman thank you council williams
thank you chairman that's four thank you
council wilson
for chairman councilwood oh thank you
chairman
i'll go back to councillor ionu
can
i think he's left the meeting okay i'll
come back to you
that members is unanimous 34 in favor so
that item has been approved thank you
members i shall now take item nine on
the agenda report on urgent decisions
is this noted members again i will
assume agreement unless anyone clicks on
the raise
hand icon
there's no such indicating indication
members
that has been noted thank you very much
has been noted members thank you agenda
item 10
report of the leader on the work of the
executive
um councilwood will provide a verbal
update to council
council on the work of the executive
since the last full council meeting
councillor wooden thank you chairman
members the meeting has already received
the minutes
of meeting of the executive held on the
4th of november
when the quarter 2 20 20 21
financial management report was noted
i'm happy to provide
an update for information purposes on
business
dealt with by the executive since then
at its meeting on the 2nd of december
the executive noted the plans for the
recreation
of the council-led legal event project
and agreed that the portfolio holder
with responsibility for
tourism works with the acting managing
director to achieve a suitable
commemoration 2021
it also approved the extension of the
current leisure contract with fusion for
a period of three years
taking it to the 31st of march 2025
with the following changes the freight
house
the mill arts and event center and
castle hall to remain closed
following the national enforced closure
between the 5th of november
and the 2nd of december
portfolio holder decisions have been
taken that have
agreed the suspension of parking charges
in all council car parks
on saturdays during december prior to
christmas
responded to the planning for the future
government consultation
agreed the authority monitoring report
2019-2020
publication as part of the council's
evidence base
for planning and published the housing
delivery test action plan 2020.
i would german just like to add that the
provision of free parking
in all the council car parks during
december to support residents and
businesses
nearly didn't happen this year a
decision calling notice was submitted
at the last moment after drawing
attention to the fact that this would
stop the decision being implemented i'm
absolutely delighted to say that the
call-in was hastily withdrawn
and residents have the benefit of free
parking on saturdays through december
and that will obviously give benefit to
our business as well
thank you very much
thank you council woodson i shall now
take members item 11
motions on notice
members before motions on notice
the first motion on car parking for nhs
staff and social care workers is set out
in paragraph 1.2 of the report
council hoy would you like to summarize
and speak on your motion
unnoticed thank you yes thank you
chairman
i will do or just call it up
um during that pandemic
council officers took the a decision to
not charge nhs staff and social care
workers for parking in the council run
car parks
whilst we wholly support this decision
we believe that is
that it is that it is fundamentally a
policy decision
and as such should be ratified by
members we propose that
one the action taken by officers in not
charging nhs staff and social care
workers
for parking in the council-run car parks
is formally ratified by council
as a member decision rather than
remaining in the remit of officers
two all nhs staff and social care
workers may part for free in all
rochford district-run car parks
upon displaying supporting official
evidence on the vehicle
this will be effective until it is
reviewed by the first council meeting
of the municipal year of 2021-22
thank you council lahore council wilson
will you be
seconding that motion
uh yes i am chairman thank you
councillor wilson
members are there any questions council
mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i was hoping that
you'd ask um if we had any questions on
the chairman's report but you didn't but
as it's slightly linked to this subject
i'll bring it out the
as i understand it the calling that was
for
more than just the saturday parking that
we've done every year
and i think one of the concerns that was
expressed
was the fact that we know when christmas
is and
most years the council seems to forget
and bring this as an emergency notice
and it shouldn't be the car parking
should be
done in a timely fashion and i
understand the
members that put the um calling
wanted to give greater um
freedom to and greater savings for our
residents not less
so that's clarity on that um and i would
certainly support
this motion i think it's an important
one and it's one that we should be
supporting
we hear a lot about the
support the nhs help the nhs
look after our emergency workers but let
this council do something
proactive rather than reactive
and i would certainly support this
motion thank you
thank you accounts mrs mason councillor
fd
thank you chairman uh through the chair
for an answer for this
the council is following guidance that
the government implemented
at the beginning of the pandemic that it
is
to not enforce parking charges in
council car parks for nhs staff members
health or social care workers this
concession for kovic 19 can only be used
when an
official duty when on official duty as
an nhs
staff member health and social care
worker or nhs
volunteer responder this will be kept
under review by officers and myself as
the portfolio holder
the motion put forward by some of the
members of the minority party seems
premature
as this guidance from government is
still in force and to attempt to make
political capital and actions taken
during the pandemic is inappropriate
and for that reason i'll be voting
against this motion and in favor of
council officers
following government guidance with no
political impediment thank you chairman
thank you councillor fd councillor
wilkinson
thank you chem um i had two questions i
think council refugees just answered one
because i
was questioning i was going to ask why
we've
we're only supporting nhs staff and not
everybody but i'm guessing from what
cancer left is just said it's because
that's what the government guidance is
and my second question was going to be
around the the governance for this
really i i
put my hands up so i don't know um i'm
guessing that this
policy that we this this motion is
trying to sort of support is already in
place
um and it's more of a question of
whether it was done correctly by
officers or whether it should be done by
members
um so i don't know which way that should
be and i'm wondering if there's an
officer or somebody that could advise me
on that
mr matt harwood white can you respond to
that question please thank you chairman
um it was a uh operational
decision chairman uh that we took at
that time
uh in consultation with the portfolio
holder um
that's that's the reason for that
decision and the um the governance route
we took
chairman thank you
mr matt harwood white uh councillor
wooden
thank you very much indeed at the time
this was implemented i was actually
portfolio holder with responsibility for
car parking um at the time
members will recall and we go back to
march
when there was an awful lot of stuff on
our plate
at the time and it was important to put
certain things
in place in fast time and we as an
authority
were actually looking at providing free
car parking we
in consultation with the assistant
director director
discussed providing free car parking for
the wonderful volunteers and we've heard
tonight about an example of
excellent volunteering but all the
hordes of other excellent examples
and we took a view that we wanted to
ensure that those people associated with
the community hub
would give them free parking and that
was actually agreed at much the same
time
as there was media pressure on the
government
to ensure that all nhs workers were
included
and quite right too the thing that i
find difficult about this motion
if we can call it emotion is that
actually it starts being prescriptive
and it could well be
that this needs to go on for a lot
longer and i think
to tie our hands to the first council
meeting
in the new municipal year is far too
prescriptive
i think it's right that we should have
the flexibility to act
according to circumstances as they
present themselves
and that is why i support councillor fd
in saying that we can't be
tied to a particular time and i think
it would be far too cumbersome to bring
these sorts of things to
members meetings all the time we do need
to be a fast and responsive authority
and what this motion seeks to do is to
slow down
that process i'm not against the
principle of what it's trying to do
in terms of providing the benefit for
our wonderful nhs staff and
our volunteers that support our
community
i am against slowing the mechanism down
and also being prescriptive about dates
but
it is for those reasons not for the
workers themselves
but i cannot support it i'm afraid thank
you chairman
thank you council woodson uh councillor
hoy
um thank you chairman i was going to
come in towards the end and i assumed
i'll kick my hand anyway
somehow speak now um i'm
disappointed in the comments by
councillor fd um
there's no need to to to make statements
like
with political capital um i think it's
quite clear that this is a
this is written on the council's web
page and it's just to say
we as counselors think we should do this
as much as
the government and at the moment there
is no certainty over when
when it may be withdrawn it might be
withdrawn tomorrow for a we know
or it might be withdrawn in two years
time i don't know
this gives certainty to to nhs and
social care workers that
they park in there today and they park
in there tomorrow and they know it's
still going to
be free um i
i would take on board what council
wooden has
said but again it's not prescriptive
because there's a review
in the first council meeting after in
the music municipal year
just to make sure that it's still
appropriate then i think
too many of our policies are
open-ended and can be forgotten and this
is a way that we
we don't forget that this is here and it
can be reviewed
yearly or every other year it doesn't
matter and
i'm very disappointed that it would
appear that the conservatives aren't
going to support this
thank you councillor hoy and council
wilkinson
you've indicated you wish to speak again
you've already spoken
so i won't allow you to speak again
unfortunately on this item
but council williams
[Music]
sorry did you hear that no councillor
williams can you try again
thank you chairman i fully fully support
councillor woodens and
after his comments on this um i'm not
sure if it's appropriate but i need to
let you know i'm not pecuniary
interested in the fact that my wife and
my daughter both
work for the nhs and do receive free
parking at the moment
thank you that will be now to council
williams
um members no one else is indicating
they wish
to speak members can you please check
your raise hand icon
and if you're not able to use your
electronic raised hand please unmute
your microphone and let me know
i will then look out for a manual raised
hand from you
chairman who is that
uh councillor stanley will there be a
recorded vote on this please
we're just about to have a have that
decision made uh
council stanley please be patient sorry
members
if anyone would like a recorded vote to
be taken please
click on the raised hand icon
chairman it's councillor obama here i
have got problems
raising the hand and i would like to
have a recorded vote
thank you councillor i own you
members there will be a recorded vote if
you can now
um put your hands down i'll be obliged
members as i said it will be recorded
vote and you know the procedure
counselor mrs belton
thank you against thank you council mrs
butcher
thank you chairman against thank you
councillor cannell
for the motion chair thank you counselor
mr carter
against chairman councillor mrs carter
you fully support this motion and for
thank you myself against the motion
counselor fd
thanks to the motion thank you chairman
thank you counselor eves
thank you council mrs gooding
okay thank you chairman councillor
hazelwood
abstain thank you
council hawkway good to see you
councilway
what is your vote thank you very much
chairman
um i would uh be voting for the motion
thank you thank you
councillor for the motion chairman
council hudson against
council ionu for the motion
chairman thank you councillor mr lucas
gill
against german councillor mrs lumley
against councillor mrs mason
all the motion council mrs macpherson
against alexa merrick
against councilman
councillor meal against
capital newport for the motion
thank you councillor mrs pavlin against
thank you council mrs rowe thank you
chairman against
thank you councillor mrs shaw thank you
chairman against
council mr shaw against
thank you council smith against
council sparing against council stanley
for the motion thank you council steptoe
hey thank you council ward
hey guys thank you chad council webb
against thank you chairman council mrs
weston
thanks jim council west
wilkinson uh on the basis i still have
unanswered questions i'm gonna abstain
jim
thank you councillor williams that will
be against thank you chairman
council wilson oh chairman
thank you council wooden against thank
you chairman
remembers that motion has been defeated
there were 10-4
24 against and two abstentions
thank you
chairman if i may can you check those
figures please because i didn't add up
i will be spare with this council ahoy
okay so mr hoy council burton is an
apology
so it does add up 10-4 24
against and two abstentions sorry i made
it
36 people voted but on another on a
different point
before council hawkway was here you said
there were 34
voting on a previous vote and now he's
here
he's certainly 34. that was because
cancer ioni wasn't here
at that particular time against the high
right thank you i think it's
for people watching i think we need to
clarify these votes much more clearly
thank you
excellent
members the expectation on notice
relating to the mothballing of the mill
arts and events center and civic suite
has been proposed by council newport
council newport would you like to
summarize and speak to on your motion
of notice please thank you chairman
the council is currently in the process
of mothballing
the mill art center at the civic suite
both in rayleigh this council
is requesting that officers explore the
possibility
of using these buildings to provide
either of the following
with an interim formal report at the
next full
council one
accommodation for new small and emerging
business
on affordable short-term rents including
shared office space with flexible rental
arrangements
this will allow businesses to see if the
business is viable
and also allow for start-up businesses
easy affordable access to the high
street
two temporary accommodation for homeless
people
thank you chairman thank you council
newport council eves
are you second in the motion
counselor eaves
your new counsel eaves
council newport do you have a second uh
for this motion please
councillor wilson wilson has his hand
raised chairman
council wilson yes thank you thank you
chairman
in the absence of cancer raise i would
like to second this motion
thank you councillor wilson council
woodson
chairman thank you this item under the
motions section
suggests that the mill arts and event
center and the civic suite
could be used for two purposes
accommodation for new
small and emerging businesses on
affordable short-term rents
including shared office workspace with
flexible rental arrangements
and or temporary accommodation for the
homeless people
however well-intentioned both these
ideas
are impractical and i will explain why
a few weeks ago and as a result of the
pandemic
the council faced a very difficult
decision to focus on keeping our most
popular leisure centers open
but that meant regrettably that we had
to close
the events venues which included the
mill arts and events center
the significant costs which ultimately
have to be borne by our residents
who are council taxpayers could not be
justified
this site and the civic suite are part
of the council's asset delivery program
which schedules them for redevelopment
in the case of the civic suite
this is due to start in autumn 2021
less than a year away for the mill hall
the redevelopment of the site is
currently scheduled to commence in
autumn 2022
less than two years away i can assure
members that the council is very aware
that although a brand new purpose-built
multi-functional community center is
planned for rayleigh
which incidentally will be much more
attractive to many community groups
where the higher of such large halls is
at present not practical
the closure of the current mill hall
will in the meantime
and for a reason solely due to the
pandemic leave a significant gap for our
residents
and for that i am truly sorry
recognizing this at the executive
meeting the 2nd of december
members gave a commitment to bring
forward the timeline
for the development of the new
standalone community building
discussions are ongoing
and i hope to be able to make an
announcement soon
but i am optimistic that the upside of
having to close the mill all
sooner than we would have liked may
enable us to bring forward
the opening of the new centre by
possibly as much as a year that means
summer 2022 just over
18 months away also
i am pleased to tell you that we are
currently in conversation with the nhs
about how we can assist in the rollout
of kobit 19
vaccination centers whether any of our
civic sites
including the mill hall and on an intro
measure be useful in the national
approach to combat this terrible virus
if we were to seriously contemplate
carrying out what this motion is
proposing
within the very limited time available
before the sites have redeveloped
as per the asset development program a
major conversion program would have to
be undertaken
with all the time and work that would
entail in order to meet
the required standards to lease the
space on the commercial market
furthermore having done some financial
estimates
of such a scheme the irrecoverable costs
of such a project
for such a limited period of time could
amount to up to a million pounds
the creation of accommodation for the
homeless would further add to the cost
given the need for additional building
regulation
and housing licensing requirements
change of use would also be required
quite separately the authority has
already entered into long-term
lease agreements to provide two local
temporary accommodation sites
and our focus is now on the delivery of
settled
affordable accommodation so in summary
chairman
in the limited period of time available
to formulate a business case
deal with planning and meet other
regulatory requirements
and do the conversion works the idea is
just
not feasible whilst it may be
politically opportunist
rather than having a strategic approach
to supporting businesses and the
homeless in our district
of which this administration has a good
and proud record
this idea is a classic example of
knee-jerk reality
of what heaven forbid would ever happen
if our opposition members were in charge
of this authority
not surprisingly therefore chairman i
cannot support
this motion thank you thank you
councillor walton
councillor webb thank you chairman
i would just like to echo the comments
that simon wootton has made particularly
in reference to the outstanding work
that we have already done in our
district to support the most vulnerable
in society
indeed we already have um facilities
available
for those that need temporary
accommodation in terms of france's cotty
lodge
and the king's head as well both of
which have been used very effectively to
support those who need
temporary accommodation and who have
previously been sleeping rough on our
streets
indeed during the kovid pandemic the
housing options team
picked up 10 individual rust sleepers
and all were accommodated within our
district
we continue to be vigilant in our
commitment to enroll sleeping locally
and i'm pleased to say that at the
moment with the the buildings that we
have
within the district we are able to meet
that need thank you chairman
thank you council webb council wilkinson
thank you chairman um i think i know
what the answer the first one of these
two questions is going to be um
because of what the leader has just said
and i've also had a conversation with
matt hard like myself regarding this
when i saw this motion
and my first thought is the cost to the
council to actually
do this because it's um it's obviously
going to cost a lot of money to open the
building and make it ready for
the proposals within the motion so i
don't know if
uh any anybody's got any idea what that
is because i know mr hardwood white
certainly hasn't or didn't when i spoke
to anyway
and the other question i was going to
ask is um
i'm no businessman but i would imagine
that the current situation we're in
um this is not the time that businesses
new businesses are coming forward i i
don't know i'm happy to be proved wrong
with that
do does anybody know or do the proposers
know how many businesses
we have waiting that could actually use
this building if it were to be open for
the
their purpose that purpose
thank you council wilkinson mr matt
harwood white would you like to comment
on both of those points
chairman i could only really comment on
the um
the there was a question regarding
conversion costs
um chairman we don't have a
specification or a scope
or any detailed plans we would need that
to work up a detailed proposal there's
been no time to do that given the
limited time available but the leader
chairman did refer to some high level
costings within his response
but as i've said here on a full scale of
scope and specification would be
required
to work up detailed costs for the motion
chairman
thank you mr matt harwood white um
council smith
thank you chairman i believe this motion
is
ill-considered opportunist
and just full of political motivation
councillor webb councillor whatton
have mentioned what a fantastic job we
as a council
are doing and have done with our
homeless
the location suggested a wholly
unsuitable
and absolutely inappropriate there's no
demonstrated need for this i can only
presume
that without consideration of the facts
the motivation behind this
is to create perhaps rayleigh
or the district as a homeless hub
for a wider area and i'm presuming
that the car parks will be the hub for
the homeless traveler population as well
there's no way i can support this
thank you council smith councillor eves
thank you apologies for the it problem i
had earlier on
my computer decided to lock me out just
shortly over there
um two things really um i am a
businessman
i have been in business for a number of
years and
i do see opportunities at the moment the
biggest problem that there is
is for people who are actually starting
business at the moment
the expense would be extreme
the thinking behind this is that the
expense actually is kept
down and we are encouraging businesses
and there will be people who are
actually made redundant
for instance who will be having ideas as
to what they should be able to be able
to do with their future
they may have ideas that may float may
not
but without help they will not be able
to
uh find out whether that will actually
happen
the the comments that have come so far
have been very much on the homeless
sort of side of things i think the
homeless side of things has been
overstated
if i'm honest we have done a brilliant
job
with homeless in the area but the
homeless issue
for these particular buildings i think
is a secondary one
i think the actual idea of promoting
new businesses especially to help
businesses
with what would be the extreme um cost
involved with setting up a proper
business on high street
is actually an idea that is worth
working on i actually
had this idea a few weeks ago and i've
been wanting to speak to
a portfolio holder and officer but due
to work commitments i just have not had
the time
but one thing i will say is that i'm
seeing a recurring thing this evening
that there have been issues that have
been put forward which have been to our
communities benefit
to such so far and they've been made
political
by the administration now i find that
quite honestly
disgusting they are if you look at the
the thinking behind these they are not
political
they are looking at the benefit that we
can actually as a council
give to our residents and to make them
political i think is quite honestly
frustrating and disgusting but um i will
obviously be supporting this
um uh this proposal and i think it's
very short-sighted for the council just
to dismiss it
to say that it's gonna cost a million
pounds i think you you
i don't know where you're getting those
figures from but i'd be very interested
to see where they've actually been
worked up from
as a businessman i can see where things
could be set up for a lot
less money than that to encourage
businesses in our area
i'd like to think that we are a council
who encourage business in this
area the the mood that i've heard from
administration members at the moment has
been very much the opposite
i'm sorry to say thank you
thank you council reeves council hawkway
thank you chairman um one thing that uh
seems to be a bit contradictory to me is
that um
on some comments relating to the
previous motion was the fact that um
some of the arguments against it was
that uh the administration needed to
um you know be free-handed so it could
act quickly and decisively
and make decisions uh without um
the the need to to have their decisions
slowed down by um democratic process
but yet um on this matter um
where there's a there was an opportunity
to
um to be um uh
forward thinking and and to act quickly
and decisively
and use uh assets uh for what was
uh ultimately um in the motion a
short term um benefit
as um it seems to be um
got the complete opposite uh concept
where
the administration is lumbering slow and
and and slow to react to a to a
situation which needs uh
you know our communities need help
especially uh the small business side of
things
um and i think council reeves has
put it very well in in respect
of uh that there are businesses and
people out there who are uh
in need of assistance to to you know
um get get sort of like um some traction
uh and will ultimately if if
some of these businesses and individuals
are given some assistance
they may well become a
benefit to the wider community and
actually to the council itself
because if they establish themselves and
start paying business rates
and other other things as well then
the council will benefit so there is uh
there is some
some reasoning behind this motion
and and it's not
a political thing it's it's uh it's uh
it's looking to um
to to various different ways to try and
help
our community in a difficult um
current position that we find ourselves
in thank you
thank you council hawkway members i've
still got
i eat councillors indicating they wish
to speak
um i shall take those a to no more and
can i ask the
the uh eight who will speak to be
concise um in their comments please
counselor ward
thank you chairman for for allowing me
to speak on this one
um i have to commend
the sentiments with regard
to this particular thing this motion
that's been put forward
but uh i'm afraid i can't particularly
uh commend uh its appropriateness i i
think
it's been outlined to all the members
that um the asset is being brought
forward
and we will be providing a facility a
lot quicker
i believe the leader did make an
announcement to us
just now the fact that uh he has been
approached by the nhs to
to make this facility available uh
for the vaccine and this vaccination i
believe
so you know it is being used we are
responding quickly i do
fundamentally believe in helping
business i've been in business myself
the same as many on all sides
and the simple fact is that
again i've been disappointed in the past
with how i received no support in
regards to the franciscotti issue
which was several years back where the
opposition
through whatever means they could uh
sought to attack me
in my support for francis cottie and so
you know i i welcome all the help that
we're doing for the homeless and i do
support the homeless
and the work we are doing but i believe
that this particular
this particular thing that is being put
forward
is totally inappropriate thank you
thank you council award council wilson
thank you chairman it's disappointing to
say the least that
many of the conservative members that
have spoken describe this as opportunity
opportunistic it's not the um
i would urge them to read what the
actual motion is which is to exp that
officers
should explore the cost of the remaining
uh of using the remaining
uh facilities it's nothing more than
that
and so it's you know i would just say
unfortunate this looks a little bit like
grandstanding to me
thank you chairman thank you counts
thank you councillor wilson councillor
mrs shaw
thank you chairman i'm amazed that um
with this motion it seems like
um the minority parties have made it
political by using the miller arts
centre
um obviously the people who've put this
promotion forward
don't walk the streets um that sounds
bad but walk the streets looking for the
homeless like i do
um we've got no homeless at the moment
in rayleigh
we've got none in rockford there have as
uh councillor mike webb um simon woodson
councillor songwriter said
they are all housed they uh
a lot of them are also in south end then
i go and see
a lot of them on a sunday evening to
make sure they're okay
we do they do not want to have a place
in ready because the
services that they need are enraged i'm
sorry are in
south end all the agencies if they've
got addictions or need help in
any other way our team in rdc
do a fantastic job to help them so
there's no homeless in uh
radio talk if there's any begging they
are not
homeless thank you
thank you councillor mrs shaw um
councillor mrs mason
uh thank you mr chairman
well i don't know where to start on this
it's a very simple motion that seems to
be
uh being hijacked by a political
division
and divisive comments by the leader and
it's disappointing
when on one hand in the past he said he
wants to work with other groups
but has persistently demonstrated the
opposite
when this council wants to it says it
can move quickly
for example when it wanted to rush
through the asset program
at the first council meeting after
lockdown it managed to move very quickly
but again you're missing the point
you're too busy trying to score points
this motion is very
simple it asked to explore the process
of looking at the possibility of using
these buildings
for two actions one of those being
temporary accommodation
and the reason for the concern over that
is it was because of the
confusing figures that have been put in
the council's
finances for the accommodation temporary
accommodation
we've been given over a hundred thousand
allocated
and yet we're assured it was 12 and a
half for the 10 homeless people that
councillor webb referred to
so somewhere something doesn't add up
but that's
not the main point the main point is
leaves to explore
the possibility also as councillors are
so
carefully pointed out for to help people
when people are losing
their jobs people are losing their
income if we have an
empty building and we're not just
talking about mill hall we're also
talking about the civic suite
which has got lots of small little
offices in there which wouldn't cost a
lot to convert
it needs a will it needs someone to try
and help our residents and if you think
that's being political councillor
woodson it's not
it's putting our residence first so
this motion was purely to explore
the possibility of using these buildings
to provide either of the following
it seems to me that the council's
reluctant even to
explore that possibility and i do regret
the tone
that has been expressed today i think
it's very sad
thank you thank you councillor mrs
mason councillor hi
thank you chairman um i was going to
point out what um
councillor mrs mason said this is a
motion to explore
the possibility i do wish counsellors
and officers would read the motions we
put forward
if they did they would understand that
they have spoken
to a motion that says we will use these
which is clearly not what is stated in
the motion
i after all these years i still
try to come to these debates
with the hope that we will have a high
level discussion about them without any
grandstanding without any politics
to actually bring to residence our
thoughts and our beliefs and our hopes
but so often we as
minority groups are just shot down
perhaps and hopefully you do
have a good debate in your conservative
group meeting about this
and you explore both sides properly and
thoroughly
however members of the public watching
this now will not see that and it is
very very unfortunate indeed
i am almost ashamed to be on the same
council as someone who suggests
and flies the kite to scare residents
that will have travellers in our car
parks in in raleigh
that really is not appropriate and
i'm not going to put louisa moss on the
spot now but i did re
read the last report that she wrote and
she
she does produce very good and
comprehensive and understandable reports
from her from her area and
from that report i took it that there is
certainly going to be
some issues with homelessness although
obviously it's very hard to gauge how
how much this is going to affect us when
furloughing stops which will happen in
march um
that's where i'm going to leave it i
just hope for better days and better
debates than we have at the moment in
this council thank you
thank you council ahoy council newport
thank you chairman um yeah i can only
say that i've been very disappointed
with the comments i've heard tonight
um particularly from councillor woodson
given the fact that in a meeting i sat
with him before
uh sat with him talking to businesses in
rayleigh
before he came became leader he said he
only wanted to hear
positive comments but all i could hear
from him tonight was
negativity it just seems as if
conservatives simply want to stifle
economic growth
in our district the concept of pop-up
shops seem to have eluded members
one million pounds i don't know where
this figures
what hack this has been pulled out of
we've got no detail on where this
one million pounds has come from to set
up um
any type of pop-up shops or any indoor
market
in in the mill hall i think to to
quote a figure without any basis
or evidence i think well i
i'd actually like to see the figure um
the traveler concept in the car park
well if you get travelers in the car
park that's due to the failure of the
conservatives to deliver any traveler
sites
so if we want to play politics we can
but i don't think there was any need to
play politics with this
as other councillors have said in the
minority groups
i read the motion slowly it says explore
the possibility of using these buildings
that is
all we were asking for explore
it wasn't to say this is what we need to
do
but also we'll have costs incurred by
leaving those buildings empty
we've got security to worry about
what will empty buildings bring they
could bring
rough sleepers they they could brick
bring
arson who knows so occupy the building
while it stood empty surely in my mind
is a good idea
and and also it will help plug gaps in
the mtfs
for the future we need to grow the
economy
council award knows that i'm very
enthusiastic about business and i
actually will have a lot of input into
the work that he's doing
and i really hope this isn't a sign of
things to come
thank you council newport council
stanley
thank you chairman and through the
chairman i'd like to say how
aghast i am with the representatives of
the council
all of the council is representing
the residents not just part of the
council
not just those few but is it all of us
whether we are particular politically
minded in different spheres
that's besides the point the point is
the residents have voted for us
and we are doing our best for the
residents now
as has already been said and i don't i
really do
take humbridge about this political side
of things
this council has got members and the
members put forward
ideas and if we don't put forward those
ideas
and get together and talk about these
things it will never get done
and i'm regards to think that this is
the way the leadership is going
i i think it's a deplorable situation
thank you very much
thank you council stanley um last
speaker on this item
counselor mrs belton
thank you chairman and i just want to
make a few points and i'm
not speaking from a place of politics
but from a
from knowledge and experience i'm also a
businesswoman
have been for many years and i am a
landlord
of many small businesses and many
businesses rent office space from me
now what i have seen this year is
actually most businesses many many
businesses are looking for ways to work
from home
they are not looking for small offices
to rent short term or long term they are
looking for ways to cut their overheads
all together and whilst i fully
understand
the proposal and i fully understand the
the reasons behind it and the
suggestions behind it i really don't
think
there's actually a demand for it we are
seeing businesses look for other ways to
run themselves
i've seen i work with many businesses
locally and a lot of them are taking
their business online
again to cut overheads and
i'm interested to to know why why
everybody or on the minority they feel
there's a demand
and i understand that you just want to
look at the possibility or explore the
possibility but what i would say is
there's currently a working group going
on
exploring what local business needs and
councillor newport you are one of the
members on that working group and would
it not make more sense that we explore
what those businesses
actually need and require before making
suggestions to
to have council officers looking into
something that there
possibly is no demand for whatsoever and
many counsellors have explained that
there's no demand for the homelessness
side of things
and from my experience as a business
woman as a business landlord
there isn't a huge demand for small
office spaces
in the high street or otherwise thank
you
thank you council mrs belton
members we've had a good debate on
this subject i will now put it to the
vote
members can you please check your raise
hand icon
if you're not able to use the electronic
rate sam please
unmute your microphone and let me know i
will then look out for a manual
raised hand icon members if anyone would
like a recorded vote to be taken please
click on the raised hand
icon now please
members there will be recorded vote uh
when i call your name please indicate
whether you wish to vote for
against or abstain from the motion
butcher
councillor mrs butcher
i'll come back to you counselor canal
for the most care you
councillor mrs carter thank you
fully support and for this motion myself
against councillor efti
against thank you chair councillor eves
four thank you jeff council mrs gooding
against chairman thank you council
hazelwood
for the motion councillor hudson
against thank you councillor ionu
i don't think he's with us anymore
councillor lucas gill
against councillor mrs lumley
against councillor mrs mason
totally support the motion councilor mrs
mcpherson
against thank you chairman also merrick
against elsa bill
against council newport
definitely for councillor pavlin
mrs pavlin
councillor mrs pavlin
mute daryl
i'll come back to your counselor mrs
papel and councillor mrs dro
thank you chairman against council mrs
shaw
thank you mr chairman against yeah
stanley
four the motion
council ward against thank you jim
yeah webb against thank you chairman
thank you council mrs
weston
thank you chairman tell us a wilkinson
paul chairman thank you councillor
williams
it's against thank you chairman council
woodson
against thank you chairman i'll come
back to
council mrs butcher
yes sorry chairman thank you again
council wilson
uh for the motion chairman point of all
of it there's a lot of background noise
as well when
when you speak thank you okay
i don't think that's the point of order
but we try and do something about that
counselor wilson um
councillor mrs pavlin
could i be over please carol
did you repeat that please carol sorry
chairman i think she's having problems
with her i.t at the moment
we carry on without you for the time
being count accounts and mrs babin
i'll come back to your members chairman
uh just so you know councillor uano is
back with us
thank you um cancer yuanu
um i don't know whether you heard i've
heard that complete debate
if you didn't then yes i did did you
did you hear that's debate yes i did
okay um can i have your vote then please
for again sir abstain
for the motion for to investigate
for the uh uh further um
please
members that emotion has been lost
[Music]
members that motion has been lost um
11 votes for and 24
against unfortunately we couldn't uh
decipher
councillor mrs pavlin's vote
but uh that does not make a difference
so thank you members
sorry on a point of order chairman can
we check these numbers again
because i make that that there are 36
councillors present
i'm really getting i'm struggling to get
my head around the numbers at the moment
we've gone from 34 to 36.
so are there two people dropping out at
times i
i'm just slightly confused
there are 36 councillors able to vote
one couldn't vote and 24 was against
11 4 so that's 35 councillors voting
one couldn't vote don't think yeah on a
point of order though chairman when i
said
earlier that our county 36 vote and you
said there are only 34 present
or 35 present now it's 36 present
people are going up and down councillor
mr hoy
um people met counters are coming
and going into this um
virtual arrangement and it's difficult
to collate at the time
um uh i can assure you that the votes
are correct as recorded
um by sonia perhaps i'll wait to the
next motion then before i
make any further comments then chairman
mr can i just ask for a point of
clarification
who's speaking when please say christine
i said i had my hand up but you
obviously couldn't see it
um just ask for a point of clarification
um
i accept what you're saying that members
are in and out
and because of the difficulties with the
technology that i'm sure we're all
familiar with that um it makes the
counting slightly difficult
but you've just given us a vote
and said that one member you couldn't
get her vote how is that vote being
called you may i ask is it going to be
recorded that the
um we were unable to register the vote
or will it be recorded as a
abstention or will it be recorded as a i
don't want to vote
i mean we have so many categories now
i'd just like some clarification
it would be unable to verify
her vote thank you mr chairman thank you
chairman you're mute
shaman your music if you're saying
something
members the next motion on notice
relating to voting at remote meetings
has been proposed by council mrs
mason council mrs mason would you like
to summarize and speak on your motion on
notice please
counselor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman yes this is that
this motion is an attempt to assist the
administration
so i do trust it will be received in the
manner that it
is presented and that no more political
grandstanding will be demonstrating
demonstrated again i should read the
motion out for clarity
when a question was raised in full
council with officers
about the number of declared votes
not corresponding to the number of
members present
the monitoring officer ruled that there
were four categories
of votes four against
abstain and no wish to vote
so the anomaly was put down
to the fact that someone didn't want to
register their vote
it was explained in full council that
members were not
obliged to vote unless the parent
is counting in the chamber the public
could see if members
voted or not when we moved to sue
meetings
the managing director sorry the previous
managing director
set up a protocol that again made
members votes transparent to everyone
watching
full council then decided that the
number
of members voting in each category would
be recorded
which i'm sure i totally agree with
since then
the acting managing director has altered
the method of voting
to the raising of a blue hand to save
time
in meetings however in the recent review
meeting on the first vote
no numbers were given we were just
advised
an item had been agreed on the second
item
we were advised 11 members voted for and
three members did not vote
one inquiry appeared that some members
were unable to raise their blue hand and
the vote had to be retaken
it was then stated that 13 members voted
for and there were no votes
for and no abstentions then the officer
stated there were 13 votes four
and one abstention
confusing isn't it this new system
raises concerns
neither the public nor members can see
who is voting
and therefore we lose the transparency
that prevailed before
in open council and under the
previous managing director's protocol
it is also problematical if a member who
decides not to vote
is then counted as an abstention and
contrary to what the council had
previously been advised
with important decisions being taken it
is important there is clarity and i do
understand this is difficult
however we're asking that this council
asks that the portfolio holder for
governance
in conjunction with the monitoring
officer and the acting managing director
ensures that the method of voting is
re-examined
as a matter of urgency and a
verification process is implemented
to prevent such a reoccurrence
thank you thank you for mrs mason
uh councillor hoy are you seconding this
motion yes chairman i will second the
motion
i will either speak now or later
depending if anyone else
wants to speak first
but i see no raised hands
sorry counselor row can i please ask you
to respond to the motion
thank you chairman the motion asks that
the system of voting by raising the blue
hand in the software is re-examined by
officers
there is no need to do this when we
first began to use the software for
digital meetings
it was new to all of us
we ended up using the roll call of name
system of voting because at the time it
was the easiest way to ensure
that we were conducting meetings
properly we use that system from 29th of
april to the 12th of november 2020
and members will recall that this has
led to meetings taking longer than usual
and in some cases exceptionally long
meetings particularly for full council
to date council meetings have continued
until 1047
1105 1107 10 55
and 10 34. at each of these meetings
motions without notice have taken
had to be taken to extend the meetings
in order that the business could
could be completed beyond the current
constitutional time
of two and a half hours
when standing orders for remote meetings
were first introduced on the 29th of
april 2020
it was agreed that these would be kept
under review and this has been done
the standing orders were reviewed on the
1st of june 2020
and again on the 13th of november 2020.
the changes brought forward on the 13th
of november reflect
the fact that as members we are much
more
proficient in operating in a digital way
the changes improve our system of voting
and improve the quality of the meeting
it is unreasonable to ask for a review
of voting arrangements
when this has only just been done an
inadequate
opportunity is being given to allow the
system to bed in
it also makes no sense to take a step
backwards and operate a voting system
which was time consuming councillors hoy
and newport and mrs mason
had already asked the acting managing
director to review these arrangements
and their request was declined on on
that basis before this motion was raised
it has been suggested that members of
the public cannot see the blue hands
this does not make the system
undemocratic
unless a formal recorded vote is agreed
by a minimum of a fifth of voting
members at
present at the meeting there is no
constitutional
or legal obligation for members to vote
or for the numbers of members voting to
be declared during formal meetings
i would also remind members that there
is a constitutional requirement for
for numbers to be recorded in the
minutes which has been met
since it was introduced by council on
the 14th of july 2020
members can also ask for their name to
be noted in the minutes transparency
is assured
i i do not accept that just because
we are not in a physical chamber that we
have to invent new steps to prove
that we are being democratic we are
operating within our constitution
and that is sufficient i suspect that
some members may resort to asking for a
formal recorded vote for everything
but i would suggest that this action
would entirely subvert the intentions
behind the standing orders
and instead of speeding things up such
actions would slow us back down again
and frustrate democracy rather than
improve it
the motion also asks for a verification
progress to be implement processed to be
implemented
this is also unnecessary no verification
process is required as all members are
able to see the electronic hands raised
however chairman will continue to ask
members during meetings to confirm that
they are all able to use the electronic
handrails
as we have seen this evening if any
members have
difficulties with this during a meeting
their vote will be taken by means of a
manual hand raise
the review committee meeting on the 1st
of december 2020
is being cited as the reason why these
arrangements should be reviewed
members should note that this was the
first meeting on that committee
at which this new voting system was used
yes it was not without problems
that is not unexpected but after these
teething troubles were sorted out
the committee were on on to conduct its
business
as required by the constitution
at a subsequent meeting of the executive
on the 2nd of december
the chairman kept asking members if they
were able to use their electronic hands
and the electronic voting works very
well
the arrangements will be kept under the
content review and a further report and
recommendation
made at appropriate time if required the
national regulations
enabling digital meetings expire on the
7th of may 2021
in any event so i expect government to
be providing new guidance
as a covert 19 pandemic evolves and
hopefully the vaccination
program means that in the new municipal
year we may well be back in the chamber
thank you chairman
thank you thank you councillor
council wilkinson
thank you chairman i've got a couple of
points on this sort this
item and i was at that review meeting uh
which has been mentioned and um
yes it was um there was some confusion
over the numbers but in actual fact the
acting uh
chairman in that meeting dealt with it
well i would respectfully say an
appropriate way and voided that vote and
did another one in it
and it worked um i
will never i'm afraid support going back
to what we had before
um because it was onerous and time
consuming um
however um i equally don't
agree with us doing a recorded vote for
every single vote which seems to be
happening um
i don't support that either because that
undermines the purpose of a recorded
vote
but what i do support uh which i think
is the essence of this motion
is a review of something and
now whether the timing is right or not
um
it's not for me to say i i'm a strong
believer in
and every process needs reviewing and if
there are concerns with the current
process which there appear to be from
some members
um who have brought it forward then i
think it's only fair
that that is reviewed that doesn't mean
to say that we should go back to what we
had before and i won't support us going
back to what we had before
but i do support the principle of
uh any process that the council or any
other organization has being reviewed
and i think that's and please it one of
the members has put this motion forward
but i i
think that's what the the essence of
this motion is about
and on that basis i will support it
thank you chairman
thank you council will concern
councillor hawkway
thank you chairman um yes um
i think that uh all members will
um agree that uh
the early um meetings that we had
um virtual meetings that we had were
overly long
and um there was obviously issues
uh about the uh the voting process there
um so i don't think this
this motion or even in the intent behind
this motion is
in in any way about going back
to those um that particular process
and that particular system um and i
think that um
what councilor wilkinson has picked up
is
is correct it's it's the um it's the the
requirements
to have this under constant review
um now there there has been
a number of things that were stated
there by councillor
rowe which i'm not quite so sure is
correct because
um she stated that uh we can all see who
raises their
hands well that's not quite true because
um
on the screen it doesn't have all
members on the screen showing at any one
time
so we can't see all the members and
therefore all the votes
and the issue of the
public perception is is a
is a strong issue
because if we want people to engage
and to see what the council does and
participate
um whether
in the council chamber at any time in
the future when we go back to the
council chamber
or currently uh by watching
our meetings on youtube then
we've got to make sure that
the process and in particular the
process of voting
is sound and also
that uh members of the public can
actually see that
um there is a difference between uh
physical meetings in council chamber and
virtual meetings
uh if the public attends a meeting in
the council chamber they can see
everything that goes on uh but um
with the virtual meetings uh they can't
see it all
so we have to make sure that uh the
process
uh that we have is sound
and that is is visible
to people who are viewing it on youtube
that's that's what i think thank you
thank you councillor hookway um council
ward
thank you chairman um i think councillor
i did emphasize the fact
that um we've come a long way since
we've started these virtual meetings
and there's lots of things that have
improved
enormously in the way that zoom has
brought itself
forward we as
members ourselves can click on the
participants button
and we can actually see exactly who is
doing what and where
so as far as we're concerned we are
monitoring
ourselves and we can query things that
are going on
ourselves the fact that that facility is
not available to the public at the
moment
um is is maybe something that
maybe be looking to review at a later
date
and so i do understand uh what counselor
mike wilkinson
has said that that is something that we
will always be reviewing and hopefully
we be
back in the chamber before we need
another review as far as this is
concerned
but but what i found and again i'm
echoing
what councilman mike wilkinson said with
regard to how
late many of us were kept at meetings
and what disappointed me was that the
people who
actually wanted to have the voting
process
and actually caused a lot of time
wasting unfortunately
because of that voting process
disappeared
long before the meetings actually
finished and so we lost a lot of
councillors
and i would say that the majority of
those councillors who went missing or
those who have put their names forward
to propose this i do apologize if i'm
incorrect in saying that
but i would wonder is there a log of
members who leave the meeting and the
times that they leave it
that i would be interested to see thank
you
thank you council ward um councillors
i've got
uh five councillors indicating they
still wish to
to speak on this item i would allow
those five
but no others after that uh council
newport
thank you chairman i'll keep it brief um
i think that
yeah it has come a long way um there's
been a lot of emphasis on
the time it takes to vote well if it
takes a long time
unfortunately it's probably the most
important
part of the meeting um
and we have to get it right so perhaps
it's an idea
if all members are invited to comment on
the voting process once again i think
that's already
done to see if it can be refined and
that could be put forward in a further
review and i think it
as other counselors have said it's very
important to keep reviewing these
processes because things do need
tweaking and as the software evolves
there may be different
functions that come within the software
as well that we could be utilizing
better
and everyone you know wants it to work
slick but we also need the transparency
there for the
for the members of the public and i have
raised concerns about
blue hands not being visible on youtube
as i don't think it's very transparent
to
members of the public so i will
be supporting this motion and
hopefully other members will see the
need to review this
in due course thanks counselors
counselor fd
thank you chairman um let's take tonight
we've had roll call votes all right
through the evening which had been
questioned twice
with members voting and i know you got
it correct because members weren't in
the meeting at the time
and we've had blue hands raised for
recorded votes which we've had no
questions on and he's worked perfectly
well
so i think as everybody says this should
always be kept under review
as councillor is doing and
it's we're never going to get it right
even in
real life in the chamber i know um one
night i remember one
member voting twice on one
on one issue so yeah we're never going
to get it totally correct
so that's me done
thank you councillor fd councillor
cannell
thank you chair i'll try and be brief i
i think we
as a collective would agree it uh has
has certainly got better the voting
system i think the improvements made
have
been more timely and allowed the boats
to to be slightly more transparent
um i think there was uh
a mismatch in understanding of
technologies like zoom ahead of that and
i think that's uh
narrowed as well i think more people are
familiar with the technologies
and so i i would agree with the comments
around
teething issues and some of those issues
going away
i wasn't on the understanding from
reading this that we were proposing to
go
backwards in this i think the intention
is to look at ways
to see if there are ways to continue
that movement forward
for example there are functionalities
around polling that may move us forward
um and there is a potential for
um uh the youtube stream to to be
handled slightly differently so that
maybe
um the camera is flicked um between the
two panels or
someone scrolls up and down the the
raised hands so that the public can see
it
so um there may be some small
improvements we can make around this
um but they may fall under the review
that counselor mrs rowe has already
mentioned
thank you chair thank you councillor
cannell
a councillor hoy
thank you chairman i am quite angry i'll
come to my anger
shortly i
i am yet again disappointed yet again
the administration seems not to have
read the motion clearly there was a
problem tonight
you may think i'm sick but i did not
follow the votes that clearly
i don't think it's beyond the wit of
this council to say there are
34 councillors present for this vote and
then give them numbers after that so we
know
how many voted and if there are any
missing
this would no doubt help the chairman as
well
as well as sonia no doubt
and i just find it surprising that
this council just seems unable to say
that
yes anything is worth looking at
absolutely anything that is proposed
is all nights perfect at this moment i'm
glad that some
admission members of the administration
have recognized their problems earlier
on
that is good however to fail to
recognize there are still
some problems now which are small
compared to what the earlier problems
were
but they are still there and yet again
everything is perfect
everything is perfect in rockford we
have no homelessness we heard that
earlier
the asset program is perfect everything
is perfect
i wish i was that perfect sometimes i'm
now moving on to my anger
if councillor wald wants to come to my
house
and personally ask me why i was leaving
meetings early earlier on this year i
welcome him to do so
he should not comment on things he is
not aware of
i know that can be vast in his case
but that is not appropriate to do
thank you chairman thank you for letting
me come back um
i'm really pleased to see tonight or
here tonight that uh
both councillor ward and counselor canal
have actually listened to what i've said
i've said and i'll repeat it is under
constant review
we have had three main meetings between
the 13th of november and the 15th of
december
and i think we have not given it enough
time
and as i say again we will review it
when we've had more meetings but as as
daniel fd has said this evening
tonight has worked out a lot better and
yes councillor ward you're right if you
click on the participants
page you will see everybody's hand
that's go that goes up
so thank you for that um
councillor hookway if you can just take
note of that if you can click on um
participants you will see i know that
it's not easy for everybody to operate
and i know that
you know some people keep dipping in and
out but we are where we are
i do i do have the participants uh thing
up but it doesn't show all members at
all at the same time but if you scroll
down
you can actually see all their names you
can do that if you just scroll
to chairman if it's an it training
session or is it a council meeting
i'm justifying your comments thank you
for interrupting me now that's all i
have to say chairman thank you
i repeat members time is going on and
we've got a lot to go through
and can i ask you not to interrupt um
other members and myself when speaking
thank you
sir on a point of order chairman are we
allowed to interrupt on a point of order
of course you are counselor
thank you i'll try and sum up um
i'm a little disappointed that the
council doesn't take its voting as
seriously as i would like
i accept that councillor said it's under
constant
review but when how
um constant review but they're not doing
it now it's too soon
well we've got problems there are
ways of resolving those problems i
accept it's a lot better than it was
but it's still problematical and one of
the problems that hasn't been addressed
is the confusion
over the monitoring officer giving us
another category of voting and i think
that needs to be clarified
i've never heard of a i don't want to
vote and i'm not even abstaining
a category before but but
at the moment the votes are quite clear
there's a majority but there was a vote
the other day where it was six
seven if there was an error there it
would have a fast
impact on the council if the folks we've
got important meetings coming up budget
meetings
the the voting system needs to be looked
at i'm
i've asked for it to be looked at
reviewed
that's all i've asked for and that that
seems to be
too much to ask for so fine i'll accept
that but i would like to
mention council awards comments about
members leaving
the council has a two and a half hour
uh period for its meetings for reasons
that after that point of time
members should be tired they probably
aren't effective
they may not be able to physically
sustain or they may have other reasons
and i do think this is getting personal
and i do think councillor ward
should be very careful when he
criticizes people
for that for leaving a meeting when they
have situations that beyond their
control
and i i think that should have yeah he
should apologize for what he said
to be honest i'm sure he thank you
um thank you councillor uh mrs mason
council watson you're indicating a wish
to speak but i did say earlier that i
would only allow those
that had indicated at that time so
unfortunately i'm going to
now move on to the vote
members can you please check your raise
hand icon if you're not able to use the
electronic raised hand please unmute
your microphone and let me know
i will then look out for a manual raised
hand off from you
members if anybody would like a recorded
vote to be taken please
click now on your raised hand icon
members we shall have a recorded vote
when i call your name please indicate
your wish to vote either for
against or abstain from the motion mr
chairman
um may i interrupt
i'm i'm sorry but councillor hoy
he's so upset he's um from the comments
levered at him he's had to leave the
meeting
um can you take his apologies from now
on
thank you
thank you mrs mason that is noted
we're going back to the vote as again if
once i call your name if you can
indicate please if you're for
against or abstain
councillor mrs belton against
councillor mrs butcher
thank you chairman against councillor
canelo
against chair thank you councillor mr
carter
against chairman now for mrs carter
that's the mrs carter
i'll come back to you myself against
councillor fd
thanks thank you chair
four thank council eves councillor
gooding
again thank you chairman nancy hazelwood
again councillor hookway
thank you chairman for councillor hudson
again councillor i own you
against councillor lucas gill
against chairman thank you councillor
mrs lumley
against council mrs mason
yes sorry mr chairman but uh i think
we're all a bit upset over the comments
that were made earlier
what is your vote so mrs mason
i did give it to you for the motion
thank you council mrs mcpherson
against thank you chairman that's the
merrick
against councilman
against council newport
or council mrs pavlin
against thank you chairman councillor
mrs rowe
thank you chairman against councillor
mrs shaw
thank you mr chairman against thank you
councillor mr shaw
against council smith against
council sparing against council stanley
for the motion that's a step towards
thank you council ward hey guys thank
you
thank you captain webb against thank you
chairman
thanks for mrs weston thanks chairman
thank you
council wilkinson for chairman thank you
council williams
thank you chairman council wilson
for chairman thank you council wooden
against thank you chairman i'll come
back to
councillor mrs carter yes thank you i
was having some problems um
four thank you
members that motion has failed
four voted four there were eight votes
against
27 votes thank you
chairman as a point of order could i
request a comfort break please
yeah i'd second that um mr chairman
because i i won't also want to phone
counselor
because i know he's exceptionally upset
sorry yeah
members there's been a request for a
comfort break
i will adjourn the meeting for five
minutes
um please make sure you're back in in
time because we do have a lot to
get through five minutes thank you
members
otherwise we're not gonna
be legal i don't think members there's
still one or two
members uh we're waiting to come back
but we are coron and i will continue
with the meeting
members before we go on to the final
emotion on notice
um i would like to move a motion without
notice
according to council procedure rule 14 n
to extend this meeting before beyond the
two and a half hours for as long as
practicable
in order to complete the business do i
have a second
i second that chairman thank you council
western members before we go to the vote
can you please check your raised hand
icon and unmute your microphone to let
me know
if you're not able to use the electronic
raised hand
members if anybody would like a recorded
vote to be taken please click on the
raised
hand icon
all right so we've
[Music]
there will not be a recorded vote voting
will be done by electronic
show of hands please unmute yourself and
advise me if you've been
you're not able to raise the electronic
hand and raise your hand
manually so it can be counted all those
in favor of the recommendation
please click on the hat raise hand icon
okay
i'm sorry chair i haven't been able to
raise my hand at this point
thank you council gooding
okay so hold on
somebody's name
[ __ ]
members could you please lower your
right hand thank you
good now the members who wish to vote
against the recommendation
please click on the raise hand icon
so you've got
can they stop
well you've got
one two three
four
that's right yeah basically
okay
members can i ask you to be on mute as
we're not speaking at prison
members those who wish to abstain from
voting please click on the
raised hand icon
okay so this note that's this now okay
and that is approved uh members
um that recognize motion and not on
motion has been approved
28 for three against um
and the the arrested members did not
indicate
their wish to vote thank you members
members who are now carry on with the
final motion on notice relating to tree
planting which has been proposed by
council newport
as a newport would you please like to
summarize and speak on your motion of
notice counselor newport
thank you chairman i'll propose this
motion i suspect in vain
given the mood of the evening but here
goes
this council notes that the council has
a working group to understand the
implications and recommend a policy to
this council on how it can reduce its
carbon footprint
and become carbon neutral by 2030 at the
latest
that the biggest single contributor to
climate change is the emission of carbon
from fossil fuels
the trees have the ability to soak up
carbon emissions and therefore tree
planting can offset some of the carbon
dioxide which is contributing to climate
change
forest research britain's principal
organization for forestry and tree
related research says the average
tree canopy cover figure in england is
16 percent
measured from 283 towns and cities
the rochford district has less than 10
tree cover and friends of the earth
recommends that this should be at least
doubled
this council therefore calls on the and
i must correct this
chairman because this is part of the
motion was incorrect and i do apologize
so i don't know if it needs to be taken
as an amendment but the
acting managing director to prepare a
tree planting strategy
which aims to increase considerably the
tree cover within the district by
identifying council-owned land that
could be used for tree planting
works with the voluntary sector to
deliver tree planting plans
involves schools colleges and their
pupils and students in carrying out tree
planting
and woodland maintenance specifically to
promote and facilitate residents to
enable the use of council land
to take part in the bbc's plant britain
campaign
as supported by his royal highness the
prince of wales
over the course of the next two years
so it's quite urgent that we enable
communities to do this work sets out
to create community orchards to help
improve the supply of fresh local
produce
and boost the health of the residents
identifies
sources of funding available
to the council and voluntary
organizations to pay
for tree planting i would just like to
add
this motion is purely non-political and
is to benefit
every single member and everyone in the
whole
of rochester district thank you chairman
uh chairman sorry you're muted counselor
canal
are you prepared to second the motion i
second that motion chair thank you
thank you councillor canel council
williams
can i ask you to respond to the motion
please
yes thank you chairman i wasn't
absolutely sure that was a
proposal until i'm enlightened by
councillor newport thank you i do know
the points made in the first four items
of this recommendation
as to the remaining points most of these
actions are presently in hand
in fact our carbon neutral working group
are looking at ways to reduce our carbon
footprint
along with tree planting and also
suitable locations for these
open space suitability is also being
investigated by this group
and it would be premature to preempt
their findings at this time
we are already working with voluntary
sector that's friends of
cherry orchard to improve our tree
population
along with our existing community
orchard at cherry orchard country park
the council already takes its response
the council already takes
its responsibility for managing its tree
stop very seriously
with the forestry commission recently
approving a 10-year woodland
management plan for over 100 hectares
of council managed woodland that's the
equivalent of 140 football pitches
we're already committed to managing some
of the best in ancient woodland in this
district
with this in mind i'm therefore
reluctant at this time
to devise yet another strategy action
plan
however having said that along with
officers we are working to put together
a parks for nature scheme
which will propose a suitable suite of
steps to improve parks for nature
including tree planting this we hope
will take a paper forward in the very
near future
this is not to say that we cannot do
more but any tree planting scheme will
need to be carefully considered
to have careful consideration as the
preparation and aftercare of tree
planting represents
a far greater cost and commitment than
just planting a tree on itself
i am at a loss to why this motion has
been brought in the knowledge that we
are already implementing or
investigating points made
and in actual fact the proposal is part
of that working group
and we are awaiting recommendations from
that carbon neutral working group
chairman now therefore proposes this
motion to be declined at this time
thank you thank you council williams
and councillor canal
thank you chair and thank you for that
response uh council williams it's quite
right to
uh highlights the um carbon neutrality
working group
uh it's a working group i've sat on
and worked really well with i think
um this
isn't raised with the intention of
overlapping or replacing any work in
that group it's it's
um proposed as a an item with a very
specific goal
to address um statistics that we
already have um relating to item 4
in forest research we know our coverage
is below
average for the rest of the country and
the intention here is to supplement the
efforts
of the carbon neutrality working group
uh
as as well as look for opportunities to
to work with
schools and other local communities to
uh
involve um pupils
and members of such voluntary
communities
to take part and take some of the burden
away from the council
um the the intention here is is for a
strategy to be put together
that will enable many parts of the
community to come together and help us
achieve this goal
i i therefore um
despite council um arthur williams words
um
we'll still be pursuing uh to approve
this motion
thank you chair thank you councillor
cannell
um counselor stanley
thank you chairman first of all may i
say that uh i was
pretty well flabbergasted with the
response from
council williams um i've been in touch
with
uh marcus hotten on this very subject
and he does recognize that there isn't
there is sufficient
planting of trees in cherry orchard but
unfortunately that's not rayleigh
we are talking israeli
and from what i understand at the moment
everything is going towards rockford so
they've got good
good air quality in rockford but
unfortunately rainey hasn't got good air
quality
and we could do better i think this
motion is exactly what we need i've
already spoken to
our forestry expert and
he knows very well that we could
actually plant some trees
it's just a question of finding out
where to plant them
and i do think this motion is is in some
way
putting towards a strategy that where we
can plant in rayleigh
i would like mr william councillor
williams to
to answer the question of has has the
uh committee looked at planting trees in
raleigh
not in rochford please thank you
yes thank you chairman
it's councillor sure i'm reading this
motion
but in nowhere this now got to be
amended again because it
doesn't say anything this is just going
to rock
sorry to rayleigh there's no mention of
really
only planting i'll take your point
councillor
uh councillor mrs shaw uh when i would
agree with that council stanley i don't
think this motion
is limited to um rayleigh
um
he was talking about cherry orchard and
i'm afraid cherry orchard is in rockford
is it not
yes it is but it wasn't limited to uh
cherry orchard
uh did mention that thank you
council stanley um i think that point
has been uh answered
councillor mrs shaw you wish to speak on
the subject
yes j i'd like to second uh councillor
uh williams um
to defer this just not to have this
going forward at the moment because
we've got a working group
if that's possible um you you don't need
to
uh second that counts yeah
thank you for the conversation council
sparing
thank you chairman sorry for the delay
um just a couple of points
i cannot understand why we want to run
another working group whatever whatever
you want to call it
well we've still got one of our own
working groups
out there working i mean we're just
doubling up the workload to
come hopefully come to the same
conclusion as to how we progress
these ideas and secondly
a cherry orchard does have a public
orchard
hence the name thank you chairman
thank you point to afford a chair the
motion doesn't um
request the setting up of a working
group uh
this work could come under the current
working group if that's what the council
so you feel thank you chair
thank you councillor canel for that
clarification
councillor woodson chairman
uh thank you very much indeed chairman
this is the fourth
uh motion this evening that we've
discussed
i noticed that a variety of people have
proposed these various motions
um and uh this particular one
i just get a little frustrated that
leaders of other groups have
come up with these motions but on not
one occasion have i been consulted
and it would have been nice to be
consulted because i genuinely would like
to work
to find a way through on some of this
the issue
once again on this motion is timing it's
about timing
and if we read what it says the council
this council therefore calls on the
chief executive to prepare a tree
planting strategy
well as has already been said we have a
working party
you anticipate the outcome of the
working party by forming another working
party that reports on the working party
so i'm really not wanting us to be
obstructive
but we've been forced down a route where
this is just such a pointless debate
because actually the spirit of what is
being said here
we support i suggest what we don't
support
is another governance process overlaying
another governance process
so actually we end up with semantics
about governance processes
rather than the core subject and we've
seen that on previous motions tonight
and i would urge when motions come
forward that we do see whether or not
there are ways to come forward
collectively because i agree with
comments that have been made earlier
we work in the interests of residents
and businesses and we should work
together if it's all possible
thank you chairman thank you point of
order chair once again the
the um motion does not propose more
governance structures or more working
groups if the council
sees fit this could come under existing
working groups
and existing governance structures i i
would also point members to the fact
that this was a delayed item from an
earlier
um meeting in this year and that
we did try to bring this forward um with
a portfolio holder
at that time point of order chairman
councillor canel thank you for that um
uh clarification
um who gives that point point of order
who was that please
uh councillor what sorry my word okay
councilwood chairman if the comment in
the motion
this council therefore calls on the
chief executive to prepare a tree
planting strategy
if that is not a duplication of
governance i'm not quite sure what is
thank you chairman thank you council
woodson
and councillor mrs belton
thank you um whilst i fully
um support the sentiment that councillor
canal was making and involving children
and business and residents
absolutely agree with i do think this is
something that's already been looked at
and just one point um a councillor is
mentioning about this
to do with sort of air quality and
rayleigh being somebody that's worked in
the carbon reduction industry for 20
years
i just want to make a point that it
would take an
acre of fully grown trees six months
to offset one car i'm not convinced
tree planting is going to help the air
quality in rayleigh
or rochford or anywhere else in this
kind of
um set up so yes i understand that any
tree planting is a good thing
i don't think we've got the acres
available to offset our carbon emissions
to improve
um air quality thank you
thank you councillor mrs belton
councillor fd
thank you chairman i agree with all
that's been said
but i just find this this this motion is
it see it seems strange that it's motion
is here even because if you're in a
working party you can just suggest
these points on a working party to be
part of the working party and you you
come to a conclusion with that i don't
see why we need to duplicate
again thank you
thank you councillor fd councillor mrs
mason
thank you
council mrs mason sorry i'm having a
problem with the meeting button
um right uh counselor watson has
idea has said we should consult with him
well
it'd be nice if he consulted with us
these motions were put in some
considerable time ago
councillor woodson if he wanted to throw
some light on the mata
could easily have picked up the phone
and done so so i
i don't take that criticism i think it's
unfounded
um the other point that's being made is
there is a carbon neutral
working group yes there is but the
carbon
neutral working group has done
absolutely nothing about tree planting
i've emailed the officers and asked and
the
only comment they've made is the
consideration is
ongoing last july they've done nothing
so i can understand why members want to
put this motion in
because we have working groups and the
actual word is working groups
but it seems that the groups are
postponing groups at the moment
and perhaps that's why the frustration
is coming in
from the other group members when they
they see the
administration obstensively doing things
but not
actually getting things done
um list their priorities seem to be
different and that
that's not a criticism it's an
observation obviously your priorities
are very different
but you can't say that there is a group
set up doing this when the group hasn't
done anything
thank you thank you council mrs mason
councillor wilkinson
chairman um sorry chairman
councillor williams has got his hand up
i don't know if that's a point of order
to interrupt
who just wants to speak council
wilkinson you can speak please okay
thank you
um yeah it's interesting i'm listening
to both sides of this and i
i hear exactly what um you know
councillor williams and councillor
wouldn't have said
um with regards to this work is already
ongoing
um so i understand their argument
entirely but then i i hold counselor
canelo in a high regards and so there's
no
he's very sensible man who's not going
to sit there and suggest something
that's already ongoing so
i'm really interested to know because i
genuinely don't know
what the the the aim is over and above
the the the existing working groups
because i'm sure that's not lost on here
maybe
um councillor canal um could just help
me with that and
maybe councillor mcpherson might as well
see i i understand that she's the chair
of the
carbon neutral working group um i'm
genuinely interested to know i mean i
agree with the sentiment we shouldn't be
doubling up
entirely but there's clearly a desire or
some um a thought process here that's
that's this isn't doubling up and i'll
just be interested to investigate that
and find out
what that is if that's possible
thank you council will wilkinson council
williams
thank you chairman i may be able to give
a little bit of clarification here
um as being portfolio heard of the
environment i agreed to meet with
councillor newport to discuss the merits
of this proposal
we met in september this year with
officers
and to look at the potential of
developing a strategy
officers since that time have visited
sites and identified potentially
suitable areas for tree planting however
there is not only merit implanting trees
but also in relaxing the mowing in some
some of the parks to provide a range of
habitats that can
can be a haven to wildlife any tree any
tree
strategy will need to be part of a wider
parks for nature scheme
um the parks for nature scheme will not
just consider tree plant
planting but also the creation of wild
flower meadows
another refuge for habitat for wildlife
in our parks
and as far as councillor sandy perhaps i
could help him jerry orchard actually
does go into rayleigh
if you're not aware of it it does go
from rockford
to grove woods which is part of cherry
orchard i hope that helps you
thank you council wilsons william sorry
my apologies
um council mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman um i've listened
to everyone's comments i was quite
surprised that
this wasn't uh put to me as councillor
wilkinson
has pointed out as chair of the carbon
neutral working group
um yes we have looked at tree planting
amongst
a myriad of other avenues to follow
to reduce our carbon footprint the work
is ongoing
obviously officers time is precious at
the moment
and a meeting date is imminent for our
next working group
at which point this would be on the
table to discuss
at that group thank you chairman thank
you councillor
mrs mcpherson uh councillor ward
thank you very much chairman um there
was a little bit of
information that came out of a factual
bit of information that came out from
councillor
daniel belton which i had no idea about
about an
acre an acre of trees would
only offset one vehicle i had no idea
that it was that amount that that is
absolutely amazing i'd like to thank her
for that bit of information
thank you council award um members
there's some two
other members uh indicating their wish
to speak
i would allow those two and no more are
indeed counselor canal who seconded
the motion and council newport
councillor canal
if you could go first please
thank you chair yeah i just wanted to
come back and address a
few of the points raised uh so council
alton uh thank you for for clarifying
uh the reasoning behind your comments i
i i would accept that it's open to
interpretation on that
and uh we'll take on board uh how we
word motions in future to avoid such
confusion
um to reiterate again though that this
wasn't an intention to bypass
or duplicate or circumvent
the carbon neutral working group i uh
again
um reiterate i very much enjoyed working
with that working group and would not
want to alienate any of
its members or undo any of its aims a
timeline
um on this was it was originally
prepared for february and hasn't been
amended since just brought back to
council again i will take that on board
for reflection ahead of bringing a
similar motion forward
with regards to carbon neutrality group
and and why i haven't raised it in that
forum
uh i am not aware of of any dates um for
the next meeting so i welcome the
comments from councilman fierce and that
will
be receiving one soon and certainly will
be
um raising this in that forum again i
reiterate though i don't see these
things as mutually exclusive we do have
figures that um
tell us already that we aren't
performing as well as the rest of the
country in terms of tree coverage
um and whilst discussions have taken
place in
the the working group around lots of
different things we could be doing
um such strategy would allow us to have
something on paper as to what we will be
doing
and it's for that reason again i i still
will be voting for this
motion this evening thank you chair
thank you councillor canel last speaker
council newport
thank you chair um yeah i just wanted to
come back on a
um something that councillor williams
said earlier
about the meeting date specifically he
says that we met in september
but in my calendar it was the 30th of
july
and i was told that um we would
have some sort of action points from
that
in september which never happened hence
the motions come back
to council um
councillor belton seems to pull
many things out of um the air um
we haven't got enough land to plant
trees not enough
i wonder if she knows how much land the
council has we could plant trees in
be quite interested to hear that um
the other thing is we've also heard from
the leader about
talking to him about motions because
we've made quite an effort tonight
put forward a few good motions all that
have been
um met with a lot of objection
um and saying about information sharing
but with the mill hall
i don't think that information has been
shared about the nhs people
we aren't we aren't debating the meal
hall president i think i just
i'm just i'm on the point of information
sharing
where we weren't that information wasn't
shared with us about the nhs
and that's the point i'm making about
information sharing
surely it should be two way not one way
so that's the point i'm making so
and if you look at the motion
um and one of the proposals is about
the two-year so it's the next two years
for the bbc's
britain campaign so how long do you
think we'll have to wait
if we did want to take part for a
decision to be made
to take part so that that's an important
part
of the motion because it's about
education really isn't it
about teaching we're meant to be leaders
in the community
and showing you know paving the way for
the future generations you know for the
children
for your grandchildren um
so yeah i really want you to consider
this motion
not just about its opposition members
that have put it forward
thank you
williams you have indicated your wish to
speak
but i did indicate earlier that
counselor newport would be the last
member to speak on this item and i want
now to go to
to a vote so members once again if i
could
ask you please to check your raised hand
icon and if you're not
able to use the electronic raised hand
please unmute your microphone and let me
know
i'll then look at for a manual raised
hand from you
so members if anyone would like a
recorded vote to be taken please click
on the raised hand icon now
members there will be a recorded vote so
you know the procedure
when i call your name your name please
indicate
the way you wish to vote for a gangster
or abstain
councillor mrs belton
thank you chair against thank you
councillor mrs butcher
answer mrs butcher
i'll come back to you counselor canal
pull the motion chair thank you
councillor mr carter
against the motion chairman council mrs
carter
come back to myself against the motion
counselor efti
against the motion thank you chair
councillor eves all the motion thank you
chad
thank you councillor mrs gooding going
into the motion chair at this point
that's the hazelwood
against councillor hawkway
for the motion chairman thank you
councillor hudson
against
uh four thank you councillor
against councillor mrs lumley
against councillor mrs mason
for the motion councillor mrs macpherson
against councillor merrick
against councillor milner
gaines chairman council newport
for the motion counselor mrs pavlin
uh against chairman thank you
mrs rowe thank you chairman against
councillor mrs shaw thank you mr
chairman against
councillor mr shaw against
council mr smith against
council sparing against council stanley
for the motion council steptoe
changed council ward
against thank you jim councillor webb
against thank you chairman elsa mrs
weston
against chairman council wilkinson
for councillor williams
thank you chairman that's against
council wilson
for the motion councillor wooden
thanks chairman mrs
council mrs butcher can i have your vote
please
again yeah against the motion and i
apologize i'm having trouble
muting and unmuting thank you councillor
mrs
carter can i have your vote please yes
thank you i'm having the same issues as
well so i fully support and i'm for this
motion
thank you
remembers that motion has been defeated
there are 10
votes four and 25 against
right
i shall now take item 12 on the agenda
future role of
investment board mr chairman i am
indicating
as a maya chairman ok councillor mrs
christine mason
thank you mr chairman i just want to
give my apologies
i need to leave i've got an early
appointment in the morning um for
council walls information it's 22
16. thank you and good night council mrs
mcpherson
um thank you chairman if permitted
um i would like to say that those items
that were suggested on the last motion
will be taken forward by the working
group to review within their plans
thank you thank you councillor mrs
mcpherson
members we now take agenda item 12 on
future role of investment board the
council's assistant director
will introduce the report could i ask
members that those who aren't speaking
to be on mute at all times please
angela law would you please uh
present this report thank you chairman
members the purpose of this report is to
agree that the investment board is
disbanded
with effect the investment board was
formally constituted by full council on
the 20th of october 2015.
at the time of its inception the council
was embarking on on commercial ventures
and the investment board was intended to
facilitate the promotion
and support of commercial thinking in
the manner which
best quality public services are
delivered
since then the council has progressed
various projects and the existing
pipeline of work has now been exhausted
there are no identified future projects
which will fall within its remit
the council's resources will be better
focused on delivery of its existing
projects rather than creation of new
ones at this time
the original mandate was that the
investment board would oversee a work
program projects which
linked back to the business plan
comprising of investment projects
transformation housing work projects
enabling projects and finance projects
as such the investment board focused on
two main work streams looking at the
council's assets and the development of
commercial ventures
a new project management office function
will set up support to support the work
by january 2018 the investment board was
overseeing a number of projects and it
became clear that these projects needed
to be prioritized
into gold silver or bronze projects as
per
section 4 on page 12.3 to 12.4 the
report section five of the report
details the format is currently being
dealt with by
the members of the investment board and
each of these projects have progressed
to a stage whereby it falls outside of
the
investment boards remit or the project
has run its course
the council is not proposing to pursue
new commercial
investments at this time but should an
opportunity arise
this can be agreed through the executive
or council powers
should this be agreed the appropriate
amendments will need to be made to the
constitution
chairman the recommendation to this
report is set out in paragraphs 11.1
1 and 2. thank you chairman
thank you angela law uh members
um are there any questions for angela
um councillor eves
thank you chair um i'd
like to uh just raise my objection to
this actually uh
going ahead uh for very good reasons um
which i'd like to just guide members
through
the report um in section 2.1
um mentions the intention
of the investment board which is
factual but what it doesn't do
is actually state the reason
why the investment board was actually
originally set up
and the reason that the investment board
was originally set up
was to fill the funding gap to find ways
to fill the funding gap
because of the drop in funding coming
from central government at the time
now the question to that i have there is
that
um has this
funding gap issue gone away quite
obviously it hasn't
so to be considering taking
the investment board away when the
reason for it being in existence
is still there i find it quite perverse
um section 2.2
the report says the pipeline of work has
been exhausted
is it that the pipeline of work has been
exhausted or is it that they just have
the
the administration just haven't come up
with any ideas or anyone members whoever
hasn't come up with any ideas seems
rather
preemptive to me to consider that be the
case
um the problem is i spoke to
councillor wooden um about this uh at
great lengths
um a week ago and i appreciate his time
in calling me
to actually discuss this but the problem
that i have
we're taking away the investment board
is the the idea
of coming up with ideas which could
promote
um projects within the council has
become fragmented now it was explained
to me that there will be
working groups here there and everywhere
which we can take these ideas to
but the what it's done what is this
proposal will do will take away the
forum
that there is for discussion for items
that can
be
possibly considered in the future um
the emboss i believe that the
the purpose of this report seems to
indicate that it
limits the future thinking and ideas
that councillors may come up with
to be able to promote
projects within the council
it seems to suggest that the situation
at the moment
is that there is nothing else we can do
um
the investment board should be regarded
as a form
uh a forum for consideration of and
promotion
of ideas that benefit our residents and
provide much needed income for the
council
far from considering disbanding the
investment board
my strongly held opinion is that we
should be
taking it in another direction in using
it
as a catalyst for cross-party
ideas to be discussed and explored for
the financial and physical benefit
of our residents i respectfully request
that the council does not disband the
investment board
and to note my plea to members that this
is
not based on politics i'm not interested
in politics
this is something where i am seriously
just looking at something where we can
jointly be in a position where we can
consider
ideas that come through come forward um
and uh i i have a strongly held
conviction
that to disband the investment board
would be a backward decision
for this council to make and that the
public
our residents would view it as such
in that we have decided that by
the uh disbanding of the investment
board
that there is no more uh meat
to be had from any assets that we have
in the council
and that the impression that i've got
tonight
is on the presentations that have come
forward is that this
is slightly political because it will
actually take away
the involvement of the
minorities minority groups to a degree
um because this is a it was set up
as a cross-party uh committee
that was lauded for being so
and that to
put it into different committees is
fragmenting something
where there should be a focus for
these ideas and things where we can
benefit our community
and our funding thank you chair
thank you councillor eves councillor
wilson
thank you chairman i echo the points
made by councillors i'd also like to
draw members attention
to uh paragraph or section 6.2
of the report it says the council is
committed to seeing the asset delivery
program
and connect program through to their
conclusion um
really we're only at the early stages of
this program and although we might like
to see and we would obviously want to
see this program as a success
um there is a chance that we may
need to change our strategy and i don't
think it's for the program to decide
what the strategy is
we shouldn't just continue if this isn't
necessary
and one point i would make is that in
the
the finals
sentence he says if there was a clear
and demonstrable need
for investment in particular projects in
the future
well actually one of the roles of the
investment bill was to look at the
ongoing
investment and the reason why i say that
is that um
it may be that in the future the
program the inves the the program may
need extra funding
and it's who's going to evaluate whether
that's going to be good value for money
and whether that fits with our strategy
and that was the role of the investment
board so for that reason i would say we
wouldn't want to stop it
and then finally in section 7.1 about
the risk
implications i think the risk is is
glossed over slightly
because the it says the risk is
mitigated
by virtue of the ability of review
committees calling decisions of the
executive
well unfortunately that would be
retrospective and again with the
investment board some of the decisions
were made up front so if we're calling
in
decisions the to the uh review committee
things have already happened the
executive had already made the decision
um and that leads or rather that
amplifies the point made by council
reeves
which is that um the investment board
generally was a cross-party working
group
and whereas and it's you know the the
executive isn't
and then finally i believe there's an
error
in the finals uh sentence or
of section 7.1 because it says in
addition
the oversight of the asset delivery
program is being undertaken
by a cross-party body specifically set
up for that purpose
the chair of which is the incumbent
chair of the investment board
well i sit on that um partnership panel
and the partnership panel is definitely
not the investment board
it doesn't have the same teeth and i
don't believe that it's got the same
reporting structure
and um i would like confirmation
from mr harwal white that um it has got
though
the same reporting structure because i
don't believe it reports directly to
council
and for that reason i couldn't support
this motion thank you chairman
thank you council wilson um
councillor ionu
thank you i echo both councillors with
the points they've raised
but i'm slightly disappointed in uh
the officers not uh consulting
the members of the existing members of
the investment board
the investment board has been
cancelled numerous times i know we're in
a difficult situation
but i think that an opportunity to
discuss it
discuss this point at the investment
board should have been done
the second point which i would like to
raise is the paragraph with regards to
the pro
rata i believe that the pro rata's been
calculated incorrectly and i would like
confirmation
from the officer uh because and also
confirmation of the number of
uh in each of the groups so to
understand
uh how the pro rata has been calculated
thank you very much chairman
counselor uh thank you councillor ionu
um
angela law can i ask you to comment on
that to the
point raised by councillor ionu and the
final point raised by council wilson
germany
a couple more points there with regards
to any uh
uh changing strategy which uh
relates to budget that would be a matter
and a decision for council not the
investment board the investment board
does not have those powers under
legislation to make that decision
with regards to calling um calling
doesn't just
in our constitution relate to executive
decisions
uh at present uh according can be late
to investment board decisions
um with regards to uh
the partnership panel sorry if
if um council wilson could
just clarify that question again for me
that would be
that would be great um with regards to
the prayer rata question from councillor
ayano
that's not a matter before uh um
the council tonight and it's not a
consideration of this report um
yeah if there was a problem with the
priority we could take it outside of
this
or we should have taken it outside of
this meeting thank you chairman
uh point of order chairman
councillor ionu uh what's your point of
order
uh the information about pro-rut is
stated in the report
that is the reason why i've raised
raised that
concern thank you councillor ionu
um um i suggest that uh we do take
that question outside of this uh
forum and um perhaps i can ask
angela law to respond directly to you in
respect to that
thank you councillor wilkinson
thank you chair i can i can help both
uh parties with that um
because i have actually taken it out of
the meeting and i've
um contacted sonya worthington regarding
it and she's got it in hand
um i have raised that uh and i i do take
the point it was interesting because i
was going to ask
um my initial reason why i raised my
hand because i raised it
right at the start before a number of
members spoke was to ask whether or not
rather than just disbands the investment
board whether it could be
mothballed i suppose for once for a
better phrase um so that it's always
there in existence to pull back if we
need it to be
not really understanding much about what
the investment board does other than the
asset program but i'm sure that the
investment board is more than a
one-trick pony it's more than just
more than the asset delivery program um
and i'm
and i'm sure that you know no one would
want to read into the fact that it's
we're recommending it gets disbanded
immediately after
the partnership panel is formed means
that it is but
um my concern um is that
um the the investment i mean councillor
eve says the investment board
um was formed um to look at budget gaps
now
um i have no doubt there's a huge amount
of truth in that and one of the things
that concerns me
which i'm sure concerns all members is
the budget gap that we have and moving
forward what that's looking like
um and i've been given that a great deal
of thought and i think that
the removal of any or any um
uh organization or anybody that's
looking at that investment gap is is
is the wrong thing to do the i i hope
that i'm not reading into the report
here
that the partnership panel that is
mentioned within the report
that is saying that it's pro rata only
has seven members is by
in some means a substitute with the
investment board because
my group and council juana's group is
represented on the investment board
council uh he has that seat
but we're not represented on the
partnership panel despite
me asking to be um that's not pro rata
because
every other group's got a seat apart
from us um
but i have as i've already said taking
that outside of this meeting but
i'm afraid unless somebody can convince
me otherwise i can't see a good reason
for disbanding it
thank you
thank you councillor wilkinson
councillor fd
thank you chairman um so i would like to
thank everybody who's worked with me on
the investment board
um it's great to finish something which
is set up to do
but i think this needs to be moved
forward it needs to be something else
in its place and as alluded as what was
alluded to earlier
is working groups working groups can
bring projects forward it can
work in groups can be opened up to more
than
just us members and uh council officers
because it's got a lot wider remits as i
understand
and i'm sure other things will come
through and i think
doing smaller working groups will be
pulled back to council
in whatever way they decide to run it
will be a much better idea
so goodbye to investment board and hello
to something
new when projects come along thank you
thank you councillor fd councillor mrs
shaw
thank you chairman i'm also a member of
the um investment board and i think it's
run its course i've just gone
through um the rdc website
and we in may 2019 to may
to april 2020 we met three times
july september march in may 2020 to
current date we've met twice
july and october and we had a couple of
weeks ago we had a meeting
an announcement that the meeting was
going to be cancelled
if you go into um
the constitution it actually says there
should be at least four ordinary
meetings on the investment vault in each
year
additional meetings may be called from
time to time
and as and when appropriate well
obviously that didn't happen in
um may 2000 to april 2020 so i don't
think
i think as daniel councillor daniel fd
has just said
it's now on its course i will be
supporting this motion to
disband it thank you thank you
councillor mrs shaw councillor hawkway
thank you chairman um i was
one of the founding members of the
investment wall when it was first set up
and um uh and i i
do remember uh
its remit uh at the time you know
this ship was launched with a lot of
fanfare
and um and a lot of expectation
was placed on it for the future of the
council a lot was um
a lot of time uh was put into it and
it was promoted as something that was
going to be
uh something that was going to be part
of the council
uh for for quite a long time
now um council reeves is right and so is
councillor wilson
is correct in what they have stated
and summed up about the investment board
um i'm not currently on the investment
ball at the moment but um
it's um it's either something that um
um with all of the uh as i say the
all of the fanfare of its original uh
launch
um it's either something that has uh
failed dismally for it to be wanted now
to be disbanded
or um you know there is a lack of
uh initiative upon the council to
to find uh appropriate work for it i
think that there is there should be
plenty of uh
work that the investment book can um
undertake
and uh it's uh it's a bit disappointing
that um
the uh the executive uh
doesn't seem to uh look at it in that
way um
i don't see why uh if at this current
moment in time that it
has a lack of things to involve itself
in that it should be
completely disblanded we have some other
committees on the council
that don't meet um as a regular thing
but we
we've got no intention of disbanding
some of those committees
um so um in
in that respect as what councilor mike
wilkinson has stated
uh rather than uh disband it um maybe
um it should be uh you know
gently laid aside for the moment but it
may well have
a great purpose coming forward um and i
think it's very short-sighted
if um we give up this uh um
by uh you know cross party um
uh body uh to look at
uh the future of the council um and the
other thing about what council refugees
stated
is a little bit disingenuous because the
investment board had its own working
parties
um and i'm sure that uh most people who
are involved on
uh those working parties would have
stated that uh
they were had a purpose and they were
successful and they brought information
to
the investment board which then
considered it uh
in detail before then presenting its
reports to full council
so it has got an appropriate process
um and i don't think that
uh the alternative that's been suggested
is
anything like um
as as as well as arranged and
as as what we currently have in
investment board i don't
necessarily think that it's going to
work in um
in in the same way and i don't think
you'll get the same results
so i think that it is something that is
worth
keeping because i think the council will
need it
um in in the near future
thank you councillor hawkway um
councillor stanley
thank you chairman uh i'd just like to
point out that
um with with the experience that was
or or still is at this present time
on the investment board i would have
thought that uh
those people had a great deal of
input into what the
what the council could do as as to
investments and and
and for and perhaps see a little bit
into the future
whether we would need a
a committee like that plus the fact that
this is a cross-party um
board which enabled
every those in the majority minority
groups
would be able to put some sort of
influence
into the council and give give their
quantified expertise if you like
in the the movement of where we're going
with the council
um having said that
yes um it would seem that uh the council
have got everything buttoned up as they
have rightly said and
uh as they have said uh you know
it's no longer needed because we've got
everything buttoned up
but i can't see that into the fuse that
far into the future and uh
maybe times will change when we will
need the investment board because
although the council as we already said
that
he's trying to keep all the finances
as tight as what they can it may be
that uh in the future they won't be so
tight there'll be other
other things that they that might crop
up and and we can't see that so yes i
i think that this is um this is really
not value for money
in in doing away with the investment
board i think it should be
kept uh whether and at this present time
because of the covet and what have you
they haven't had the meetings
for one reason or another but that's
that's
that's the the name of the game this
year sort of thing
next year they could have twice as many
meetings if they wanted to
so you know we i do think that we're
missing a trick here and
we should keep this investment ball um
close at hand to us so that we we can
get their expertise
that's all i'm saying thank you thank
you cancer stanley um
council wilson um you're indicating you
wish to speak you've already spoken
so i can't allow you to come back again
i'm afraid um
members there are two uh
i'd have ordered chairman um the
monitoring officer
actually asked a question of me uh which
i wasn't able to answer
and i'd also like to come back on the
answer that she gave me
um okay council wilson
i will um ask you to then to respond
to angela law's question um
but first of all i shall ask council
sparing
to speak please thank you chairman
going back many years as this
investment board started off i think we
ought to point out this was
not just to fill a funding gap it was to
look at the assets that the district
council
owned controlled how we could realize a
better operation a more efficient
operation
a more economic operation at the end of
the day
the decision came along with the asset
program
up until that point it had been fully
cross party
what i found very sad was that when the
asset program was agreed and we were
going to progress it
no members of the minority party that
have been involved
in the investment board wanted to
participate
and it was left to members of the
administration to act on behalf of
members
and i i'd like to think we did a good
job but there was
absolutely no reason why members of the
minority party
couldn't have been part of the asset
working groups
thank you chairman points of order chair
whilst i take on board councillor
sparing sentiment for this year on my
first year in council i was
part of the investment boards
and was trying to be as productive as
possible in discussions on that
i'd also note my voting record on this
item at full council in previous
sessions
thanks chair thank you
for now that's more of a personal
statement than a
point of order counts the canal but i'll
take your point
um councillor wilson um can you please
respond
to angela along the lines you have
previously indicated please
yes chairman certainly um yeah the
monitor
monitoring officer asked me um
about the um partnership panel and my
question was
that um the partnership panel has got
very different terms of reference
to the investment board and doesn't have
the um
same way same method of reporting into
the full council
and in respect of her response
i think she gave a misleading answer
because it's absolutely true
that the investment board does not
approve
the budgets of any of the projects or
programs that it's responsible for
those obviously go to full council but
those
budgets are assessed by the
the investment board and indeed if i'm
correct
um my recollection that the ict
program came back a number of times for
additional funding
which is one of the points i'm making
that didn't come back direct to council
i believe it came back via the
investment board so i would like
first of all to make the point to the
monitoring officer about
the terms of reference for the
partnership panel and secondly
that it's not true that the investment
board sets the budget
thank you chairman thank you council
wilson
angela law can i ask you to comment on
those points please
yes thank you chairman uh if with really
um in relation to the partnership board
uh
it it does just like any other outside
body that the council has
it does it it has requirements to report
uh back to members so um there is a
um that there is a requirement for the
partnership
panel to report back the partnership
portable
panel now works under we are under
contract
for the uh with the development partner
so we have now
different governance arrangements for
that
thank you angela law members
last speaker on this point on this
item counselor newport please
thank you chairman um i'll just quickly
come back on something
um council sparring said about the uh
working group and no
minority group involvement and i believe
that was due to the fact that
not all minority groups were invited to
take part
and hence other minority groups decided
that
it was all or nothing so we'll just be
clear on that
um it's a bit of a double-edged sword to
me this because
from i'm on the investment board but
it's come up with a a lot of loss making
ideas
and uh it has spent a lot of recommended
spending of significant amounts of money
but
and i am not in favor
of getting rid of the investment board
amidst a significant project
in hand and i think
the investment board should start what
is finished
so i will certainly not be
supporting the disbanding of this
um committee and uh
well i hope that other members tonight
will
vote against disbanding it
thank you council dewport um members
there are two recommendations set out at
paragraph 11.1 of the report on pages
12.8
and 12.9 one
that the investment will be disbanded
with immediate effect
two that the monitoring officer shall
make the necessary amendments to
council's constitution
and delete all references to the
investment board
both of those i will move from the chair
do i have a seconder yes chairman
councillor uh
our secondary sorry sorry sorry
mr uh councillor western
your beauty chairman
was it council western who seconded that
yes yes chairman thank you council west
chairman you're muted okay
members can i also propose that we vote
on these recommended
recommendations together take them as
one and i will assume your agreement
unless you click on the raised hand
icon
there is no such indication members and
we shall now
now vote on the recommendations as one
as recommendations one
and two members can you please
check your raise hand icon if you're not
able to
use the electronic race hand please
unmute your microphone and let me know i
will then look
out for a manual raised hand from you
members if anyone would like a recorded
vote to be taken please click on the
raised hand
icon
members there will be a recorded vote
you know the procedure when i call your
name please indicate whether you wish to
vote for or against or abstain
from the from the recommendations
councilor mrs belton for the
recommendations thank you
thank you councillor mrs butcher
for the recommendation thank you
chairman councillor canel
against chair thank you thank you
councillor mr carter
four chairman thank you councilman mrs
carter against
myself for councillor fd
four thank you chairman councillor eves
against thank you councillor mrs gooding
for the recommendations thank you mr
chairman
thank you councillor hazelwood
or council hawkway
against chairman councillor hudson
for thank you councillor ionu
i'll come back to you counselor i own
you counsel
i'm just uh i had problems trying to get
the mic on uh
against thank you council lucas gill
thank you councillor mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason she's left the
meeting councillor mrs macpherson
or councillor merrick
or councillor milne or
council newport against
councillor mrs pavling four
thousand mrs rowe thank you chairman
four
councilor mrs shaw thank you chairman
for
councillor mr shaw or
so mr smith for thank you council
sparing
or answer stanley
against the recommendation councillor
steptoe
or council award four
thank you jim thank councillor webb oh
thank you chairman
council weston for chairman
council wilkinson against chairman
councillor williams that's four
four thank you wilson thanks chairman
an accountant councillor woodson oh
chairman thank you thank you members
i'll come
members those recommendations have been
approved
25 votes for none against
no abstentions
chairman could i ask you to redo that
again please uh
did you say nine against
correct counselor stanley thank you
chairman may i just ask how my my vote
was recorded please
um who was that bespoke sorry councillor
arthur williams
council williams there was a recorded
vote yeah how was
i i did vote for i just want to confirm
that
yes for a recorded vote no for the
motion
right yes yes you did council williams
okay thank you
members i shall now take item 13 on the
13 on the agenda exclusion of the press
and public chairman asked everybody to
be mute unless i asked them to speak
council western were you did you wish to
speak
the next item is quite important and
because of
uh how late it is would it be best to
defer this to the next full council
meeting
so we're quite refreshed
in discussing it further
we've already had a vote to extend the
meeting for as long as
is required to complete the business and
we will do that
council newport damon
um as i don't have access to this
document i cannot
take part in the next vote so at 22
56 i'll be leaving the meeting
and that's councillor james newport
thank you
that's a new world can i ask why you
haven't got access to this item
i don't have access to my email and um
i'm now going to
leave the meeting and not take part in
this vote
or today report counselor eaves
apologies chairman but uh i had a very
early start uh yesterday this morning
and i have the same again tomorrow
um so i'm gonna have to leave the
meeting apology
let's tell we're saying members um i
will now take
a gender item 13.
members i cannot keep having these
interruptions
counselor stanley can you be pleased
quick
i'll be as quick as i have to be it is
down close to 11 o'clock it is now time
for me to retire
i will be retiring from this meeting
thank you thank you
council uh thank you chairman um
yes uh i have a similar situation that i
have to be
up early in the morning so i cannot no
longer
stay with the meeting anymore thank you
chairman good night
thank you
[Music]
anybody else wish to leave the meeting
no
i shall take item 13 members exclusion
of the press and public
i will now move a recommendation that
under section 104 of the local
government act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following item of
business
on the grounds it involves a likely
disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph 1 of
part 1
of schedule 12a of the act
do i have a secondary members this
chairman is
counselor carol weston thank you
councillor western
members we will now vote
members could you please
members will now take a vote on the
members can you please
raise check your raise hand icon and if
you're not able to use the electronic
raised hand
please unmute your microphone and let me
know
then look at for a manual raise hand
from you
members if anybody would like a recorded
vote to be taken please click
on the raised hand icon
members there will not be a recorded
vote it will be recorded
um electronic
it's councillor julie goodin
i'll be raising a physical hand
thank you okay
um could i ask all those who are in
favor of the motion
to click on the race hand icon please
thank you councillor gooding that is
noted
alright
um
[Music]
purpose could i ask you now to lower
your raised hands please
[Music]
thank you members um can i ask those
people who
wish to vote against the uh
motion pleased to indicate with a raised
hand
over your hands now please any
abstentions to the motion please to
indicate by ray's hand
motion is passed
uh
members that recommendation has been
passed 21
4 2 against and two abstentions
if you can bear with us please and we
will let you know
when we're able to carry on
and the live stream has been
obviously the